EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT WILL COME
TO ORDER. A GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVER NINETEEN
pPUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. IN THE SENATE CHAMBER
WITH US TODAY HERE ARE- CENTER
C. R. TWO I I'M SORRY SIMPLY
MEMBERS THEY ARE TO IS A MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ- MY FELLOW CHAIR AND-
CENTER MONIQUE LIMON MAY BE
JOINING US SHORTLY- WE ALSO HAVE
WITNESSES WERE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY AND FOR THESE REMOTE
WITNESSES PLEASE MEET YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS AS A GREATLY
EIGHT US ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASKED EVERY
TIME YOU WHICH WE RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU DO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN PROGRAMMING EACH TIME YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL BE APPEARING ASKING
IF YOU'D LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT A NEW BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU
WERE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ARMS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY AS WELL. BROADRIDGE WITHIN
WISHING TO PROVIDE BUT COMMENT
THE PARTIES TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISCREET DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. FOUR
ONE EIGHT FIVE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS NINE FOUR ONE. SEVEN
FIVE ONE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE INDOOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WE WILL BE HEARING ALL
THE PANELS OF WITNESSES ON THE
AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. THEN ONCE WE'VE
HEARD ALL THE WITNESSES WILL
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S. AGENDA IS TOPIC PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AVOIDED
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I MAINTAINED A QUORUM DURING
HERE HEARING IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. SO
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT
ALL PARTIES INTERESTED SO THEY
CAN BE HEARD. NOT A BIGGER
HEARING TODAY. WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING. AT A NEW AREA THAT
THIS. LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT HAS NOT
TACKLE BEFORE. WE'VE TAKEN A
LOOK IN OUR PREVIOUS HEARING AT
THE CLIMATE EMERGENCY WRIT LARGE
AND SEVERAL CHALLENGES TO
BUILDING A JUST FORM OF
RESILIENCE. THAT LOOKS AFTER THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE
DURING THE DISASTERS THAT. SEEM
TO CHALLENGE OUR STATE
CONSTANTLY. AND THEN I GUESS IS
THE CHALLENGE OF THIS ELEMENT OF
THE CRIME EMERGENCY WE'RE
EXPLORING TODAY WHICH IS THE
TOPIC OF EXTREME HEAT. WE ARE
NOT IN A DROUGHT. WE ARE NOT IN
A SERIES OF HEAT WAVES WE ARE IN
A GREAT DRYING AND REDUPLICATION
OF THE WEST MODELS INDICATE THAT
TEMPERATURES WILL CLIMB OVER THE
COMING DECADES. INTO INTO AREAS
THAT WE HAVE NEVER EXPERIENCED
BEFORE AND IT WILL BE DEAD. THE
QUESTION IS CAN WE MITIGATE
THESE IMPACTS NOW AND DEAL WITH
THESE EMERGENCIES BEFORE THEY
START. COURTNEY LUSKIN CENTER AN
INNOVATION OUT OF UCLA
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT JUST SEEING
THESE HIGHER AVERAGE
TEMPERATURES. BUT THE SEVERE
HEAT WAVES AND HEAT EXPOSURE
THAT COMES WITH THEM WILL BE ONE
OF THE GREATEST PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES OF THE
COMING DECADES. THEY ARRIVE IN
ACUTE AND CHRONIC WAYS AND IT'S
OFTEN HIDDEN. IT'S A HOT DAY
IT'S A HUNDRED TWENTY DEGREES IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. AND YOU
THINK HOW UNCOMFORTABLE I HAVE
TO STAY INSIDE. FIND THAT AIR
CONDITIONER MAYBE YOU KNOW A
FRIEND WHO HAS A POOL. TRY TO
GET THROUGH YOUR DAY AND LAST
THAT A SEE A ROLL DOWN YOUR
WINDOWS IF YOU'RE A SENIOR KERR
ISN'T WORKING AND JUST GET
THROUGH IT. BUT FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE HOMEBOUND WHO HAVE MEDICAL
ISSUES WHO ARE DEPENDENT ON
STABLE SUPPLIES OF POWER. WHO
THEMSELVES CAN'T ALWAYS GET TO A
COOLING CENTER DON'T HAVE A
FUNCTIONAL AIR CONDITIONING
UNIT. DON'T HAVE PROPER HEATING
AND COOLING IN THEIR HOME. THESE
INCIDENTS ARE DEADLY AND WE'RE
GONNA EXPLORE IN MORE DETAIL THE
HIDDEN HUMAN COST OF THE EXTREME
HEAT. WAIVE THAT IS GOING TO BE
FACING OUR STATE AS AN
EMERGENCY. AND ONE THAT REALLY
DOESN'T CEASE AND I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE CENTRAL TENSION
POINTS WERE GOING TO.
INTERROGATE TODAY. IS THAT
DURING A FIRE WE HAVE. UNIFIED
COMMAND THE KIDS ENACTED-
HURRICANE HITS. OR EVEN- TIDAL
WAVE. THIS IS THE WORK THAT OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS DEAL WITH. IN
FLOOD CONDITIONS THEY DECLARE
STATE OF EMERGENCY IN A UNIFIED
COMMAND CENTERS ESTABLISHED.
INCIDENT COMMAND IS ALIGNED AND
- PEOPLE AND AGENCIES. ALIGN
THEMSELVES AND THEY DO THAT KIND
OF PLANNING AND RESPONSE THAT WE
EXPECT DURING A CRISIS- THERE
ARE NO LINES BUREAUCRACY DOESN'T
MATTER THERE OUGHT BE NO TURF.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO A CASCADING
EMERGENCY LIKE EXTREME HEAT OR
IN CONFLUENCE WITH THE CLIMATE
EMERGENCY GIVEN ONGOING
SITUATION WHERE YOU NEED THAT
SAME UNIFIED COMMAND APPROACH.
BUT EFORE THE BEFORE THE
DISASTER HAPPENS AND I THINK IF
WE FOUND A WAY TO APPROACH
HAZARD MITIGATION. HAZARD
MITIGATION. WHICH HAS BEEN A NEW
IN AN EVOLVING PLACE FOR FEMA'S
WORK- NATIONWIDE IN CONGRESS IS
CERTAINLY INVESTED IN THIS SPACE
ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS. THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN LOOKING AT
MORE THESE PREVENTIVE MEASURES
BUT IF WE CAN START TO GET AHEAD
. OF THIS DEADLY HEAT WAVE THAT
IT WILL BE WITH US FOR DECADES
TO COME AND FIND A WAY TO BUILD
RESILIENCE INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SAFER AND
WE'RE GONNA BE MORE RESILIENT.
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THOSE LIVES ON OUR HANDS. RIGHT
NOW A LOT OF US DON'T WANT TO
PAY ATTENTION TO THE NUMBERS. WE
DON'T TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE DYING. AND WE
DON'T EVEN WANT TO COUNT THEM.
AND THAT'S A PROBLEM SO I'M
HOPING TODAY SHED SOME LIGHT ON
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WE'VE SEEN
IN OUR- IN OUR NEWSPRINT- THE L.
A. TIMES HAD AN ONGOING PEACE
THAT. RNLI BROUGHT THINGS TO MY
ATTENTION AND INTRUSIVE IN LINES
AROUND THE ISSUE THAT I SAW JUST
PERSONALLY IN THE COMMUNITY. YOU
KNOW WHEN WE HAVE WILD FIRES IN.
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY RIGHT
ON THE HILLSIDES IN CHATSWORTH
AND- DOWN IN THE CANOGA PARK IN
THREE NORTHRIDGE ALONG THE
NORTHERN RIDGE. THE WINDS KICK
IN THE FIRES ARE. THE FIRES ARE
EVER PRESENT AND THE POWER LINES
OFTEN SHUT DOWN. AND USUALLY
THOSE ARE ON THE HOTTEST DAYS SO
IF IT'S A HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
DEGREES OUT AND YOUR POWERS DOWN
WHAT HAPPENS I ARRIVED AT A
WOMAN'S DOORSTEP WITH EXACTLY
THAT SITUATION. WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE THERE TO DELIVER A- A
SOLAR BATTERY KIT THOUSAND
DOLLAR YETI THAT- THE SOCAL
EDISON IS NOW DISTRIBUTING
THROUGHOUT THE SOUTHLAND PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY PS PS. BUT
THAT DAY. THAT SYSTEM- WASN'T
ENOUGH FOR HER- AND THE TRIP TO
THE HOSPITAL AND THE EXPERIENCE
IS GOING THROUGH THE I. C. U.
AND- YOU KNOW. WE DO IT'S A REAL
THING AND- AND WE KNOW THEY'RE
COMING AND SO IF WE KNOW THESE
EMERGENCIES ARE COMING WE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO GET AHEAD OF
THEM. THOSE ARE MY OPENING
REMARKS BUT THE OTHER THING I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT HERE TODAY IS
THAT THIS WILL BE OUR FIRST
OPPORTUNITIES A LEGISLATURE. TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE DRAFT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S EXTREME HEAT ACTION
PLAN. THEY PUT FORCED THIS
DOCUMENT- IN RECENT WEEKS AND
I'M I'M THRILLED TO HAVE. THEIR
LEAD SPOKESPEOPLE IN SOME OF
THEIR KEY AGENCY FOLKS. COMING
OF THIS HEARING TODAY TO HEAR
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S PLANNING I
APPLAUD GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
FORGETTING PROACTIVE IN VERY
INTENTIONAL AND CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL ABOUT THIS. I
THINK THE REPORT AS A GOOD HIGH
LEVEL START- TO REALLY CREATING
A UNIFIED EFFORT THROUGHOUT
GOVERNMENT. AND FOR PICKING UP
THAT BALL WE ARE TRULY GRATEFUL
IN THE HOTTEST PARTS OF THE
STATE. SUSANJUST A LOS ANGELES
ISSUE WE KNOW THIS IS CENTRAL
VALLEY WE KNOW THIS IS. THE
INLAND EMPIRE WE KNOW THIS GOES
DOWN OUT TO SAN DIEGO WE KNOW
WHAT'S IN THE FAR NORTH. HE
DOESN'T DISCRIMINATE. SO I'M
GRATEFUL TO HAVE MY COLLEAGUES
HERE TODAY- FROM. FURTHER DOWN
IN THE SOUTH LANDING AND EVEN
FURTHER SOUTH THAN THAT- SO I
WOULD TURN IT OVER TO MY VICE
CHAIR. THE MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
OFFER YOU SOME OPPORTUNITY SOME
OPENING REMARKS THANKS. YES I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR STERN FOR
HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
ON EXTREME HEAT EMERGENCIES. AS
YOU KNOW OUR CHANGING CLIMATE
RESPONSIBLE FOR RISING
TEMPERATURES THAT ARE CALIFORNIA
WORK EACH YEAR ROUTINELY SEE
RECORD BREAKING DAYS OF HEAT.
OURS AS A RESULT OF ONE OF MOST
SERVERS THREAT TO PUBLIC HEALTH
OF CALIFORNIANS COME FROM THE
HIGHER FREQUENCY OF EXTREMELY HE
CONDITIONS. AND ATTENDED A
CALIFORNIA HEAT WAVE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX OVER SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY FIFTY PEOPLE DIED DUE TO
HEAT RELATED CONDITIONS. THE TWO
THOUSAND SIX CALIFORNIA HEATWAVE
SAW AN INCREASE IN EMERGENCY
VISITS AND HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR
HEAT RELATED ILLNESSES
ESPECIALLY AND THE NORMALLY
COOLER COASTAL COMPANIES.
HEATWAVES ARE SOCIALLY WITH
INCREASED HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS
FOR CARDIOVASCULAR KIDNEY AND
RESPIRATORY DISORDERS. OLDER
ADULTS THE VERY YOUNG AND PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESSES AND
CHRONIC DISEASES ARE ALSO AT HER
WRIST DURING EXTREME. HEAT
HOWEVER. EVEN YOUNG AND HEALTHY
PEOPLE CAN BE AFFECTED IF THEY
PARTICIPATE IN STRENUOUS
PHYSICAL ACTIVITIES. CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN ESTIMATED TO HAVE MORE
THAN ONE MILLION PEOPLE THAT ARE
SPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO EXTREME
HEAT. WAVES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
BECOME MORE FREQUENT AND TENTS.
LONGER LASTING OVER THE PAST
FIVE DECADES ONE STUDY FOUND
THAT IN LOS ANGELES WILL
EXPERIENCE AN AVERAGE OF TWENTY
TWO EXTREME HEAT DAYS ANNUALLY
BY TWENTY FIFTY. HOW FROM SIX
DAYS IN THE PERIOD FROM NINETEEN
EIGHTY TO. TWO THOUSAND.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA AVERAGES
THIRTY FIVE DENVER C. DAYS A
YEAR BY TWENTY FIFTY THE STATE
IS PROJECTED TO ALMOST FIFTY
SUCH DAYS A YEAR. EXTREME HEAT
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF HEALTH
EMERGENCIES IT IS ALSO CREATING
OTHER EMERGENCIES THAT SEVERELY
THREATENED CALIFORNIA. EXTREME
HEAT AND CLIMATE CHANGE IS
COMING CALIFORNIA'S TREES AN
INCREASE IN RATES. AND THIS I'M
PERCENT A NUMBER OF DYING TREES
CREATING UNCOMMONLY DESTRUCTIVE
AND DEADLY FIRE SEASONS. I
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO STUDY CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE TO EXTREME HEAT
EMERGENCIES ESTABLISHING A
COMPREHENSIVE POLICY. TO ADDRESS
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR LUCK LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS WILL SAVE LIVES. ALSO
MISTER CHARACTER PERMISSION I
WOULD LIKE TO READ A STATEMENT
ON BEHALF OF. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS WAS UNABLE TO JOIN US FOR
THIS HEARING YES ABSOLUTELY. I
WANT TO THANK FIRST OR BY THANK
YOU BOTH THE CHAIR THE VICE
CHAIR OF ORGANIZING THIS JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE. ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT HEARING ON
EXTREME HEAT. THIS IS AN ISSUE
OF ELEVATED SINCE MY ARRIVAL TO
THE LEGISLATURE. AS A
REPRESENTATIVE TO A LARGELY
DISADVANTAGED LATINO COMMUNITY
EXTREME HEAT IS MORE THAN JUST A
CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUE THAT THAT
ALSO ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUE
. WHERE IS THAT EXPERIENCE
EXTREME HEAT OFTEN HAVE LARGE
EXPANSES OF CONCRETE LESS
GREENERY A HIGHER DENSITY
HOUSING. LOWER AVERAGE INCOMES
AND POOR HEALTH STATUSES. AND HE
IS ONLY WORSENING THE FIVE
HOTTEST YEARS ON RECORD ARE
201-520-1620 SEVENTEEN. TWENTY
NINETEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY. YEAR
AFTER YEAR WE HAVE WITNESSED
RECORD BREAKING HEAT WAVE THAT
HAVE LED TO MORE POWER OUTAGES
COMPROMISED WATER QUALITY
INCREASE IN POLLUTION AND MORE
INTENSE WILDFIRES. BY SURE
AUTHORED AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
WHICH WOULD HAVE COORDINATED
STATE EFFORTS TO HELP URBAN AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES COMBAT
EXTREME. HEAT BY CREATING THE
EXTREME HEAT AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCY PROGRAM UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH. THE PROGRAM WOULD
ALSO ESTABLISH CALLING FOR
COPPER AND COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROCESS THAT WOULD HAVE HELPED
LOCAL ENTITIES COMPLETE MEASURES
THAT REDUCE EXTREME HEAT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL'S HELD IN
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS BUT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING TO ELEVATE
THIS ISSUE OF EXTREME HEAT AND
BRING THE ATTENTION. THAT THE
ISSUE DESERVES I'M GREAT FOR
JUST THAT AND FOR THE FIRST
TIME. EXTREME HEAT IS BEING
ANALYZED AS OF MARCH A CRISIS
THAT IT IS. WE NOW MUST ACT TO
PREVENT HEAT RELATED ILLNESSES.
BETTER PER LOCAL KOMMER
COMMUNITIES FOR THOSE EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS AND BUILD
RESILIENCY INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THIS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ISSUE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIR- SOME MEMBERS
SAY ART OF YOU WANT TO MAKE IT.
JUST A WELCOMING COMMENT HERE.
THANK YOU. YEAH THERE BUT TO
PUSH. FOR MINOR THERE WE GO. I
THANK YOU FOR CHAIR FOR HAVING
THIS IS A CON- BEING PREPARED
FOR HEAT IS LIKE BEING PREPARED
FOR ANY OTHER EMERGENCY I'M SURE
BACK EAST- THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WISHING THEY WERE MORE
PREPARED FOR THE COLD. AIR
EXPERIENCING AN EXTREME EVENT IN
IN BACK EAST RIGHT NOW WE PRAY
FOR ALL THOSE PEOPLE. BUT
THERE'S TWO THINGS THERE'S AN
INDIVIDUAL COMPONENT AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO THAT THERE'S
ALSO GOVERNMENT RESPONSIBILITY
AND- PART OF THAT INDIVIDUAL
RESPONSIBILITY IS KNOWING YOUR
OWN- SITUATIONS AND PLANNING FOR
THAT AHEAD OF TIME. THE
GOVERNMENT RESPONSIBILITY IS TO
HELP RAISE AWARENESS OF COURSE-
SO THAT PEOPLE KNOW THAT- IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT THEY NEED TO
PLAN FOR. BUT IT'S ALSO TO
ENSURE THAT THE BASIC THINGS
THAT THEY NEED TO DEAL WITH
EXTREME HEAT ARE AVAILABLE WHEN
THEY NEED IT. ENSURING WATER
SUPPLY AND DISTRIBUTION.
OBVIOUSLY IS A FIREFIGHTER I
GUESS WHAT WE BATTLE HEAT WITH
WE DO HAVE A LITTLE WITH WATER.
AND SO ENSURING A WATER SUPPLY
SO PEOPLE CAN USE THAT FOR
COOLING MEASURES WHEN THEY NEED
IT AND THE DISTRIBUTION. ARM AND
THAT- THAT THAT ENCOMPASSES
EVERYBODY IN THIS STATE- ALSO
ENSURING ADEQUATE ELECTRICAL
SUPPLY AND DISTRIBUTION BECAUSE
THE OTHER COOLING THAT PEOPLE
TAKE OR IN WHAT THEIR CONDITION
IS AN ACTOR. ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
HAVE A HIGH HEAT EVENTS- THAT
CREATES QUITE A STRAIN ON THE
CURRENT DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM. AND
SO IT'S AND IT'S INCUMBENT ON US
IN THE GOVERNMENT TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE SUPPLIES ARE ADEQUATE. AND
FOR THE MOST EXTREME- TIMES IN
OUR IN OUR- CYCLE FOR THE YEAR-
I ALREADY TALK ABOUT RAISING
PUBLIC AWARENESS BECAUSE THAT'S
SOMETHING ELSE IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR US TO DO. BUT ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING IS A
PROVIDING FOR THOSE THAT CAN'T-
THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE AS
POINTED OUT BY MY COLLEAGUES
THAT- DID YOU NEED TO- INDEED
NEED HELP IN THAT DEPARTMENT AND
IT'S OUR JOB TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN BEST HELP THEM
GET THROUGH THESE. THESE EVENTS
. ACCURATELY UNDERSTANDING THE
FUTURE AND PLANNING TO DEAL WITH
IT THAT'S OUR GREATEST
RESPONSIBILITY. AND SO WE NEED
TO DO- THIS THIS I THINK OPENS
UP THAT CONVERSATION. BUT THE
BIGGEST THING YOU NEED IS TO
HAVE THE TOOLS AND A PLAN BEFORE
YOU NEED IT. AND NOT TRYING TO
GET IT. DURING THE EVENT BECAUSE
A LOT OF TIMES WE START THINKING
MORE ABOUT WHEN HE COMES. HOW WE
GET PEOPLE HELP WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THEIR
TOOLS THAT THEY EED PRIOR TO.
SO WITH THAT I AM HST HERE FROM
SOME OF THE EXPERTS- AND THE
TESTIMONY THAT THEY HAVE TO
OFFER US AND- AGAIN TO BUY
PRECIADO YOUR INTELLIGENCE AND
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR YOUR VALUABLE INPUT AND
LIVED EXPERIENCE HERE IT WILL BE
AN ASSET TO THIS COMMITTEE- I DO
WANT TO GET STARTED WE HAVE A
PACKED HEARING AND- YOU KNOW IT
THE PANELISTS ALL KNOW THIS
ALREADY BUT I'LL JUST MAKE ONE
MORE REMINDER SO. WE ARE GOING
TO DO VERY SHORT- IT'S OF
TESTIMONY SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE.
THREE MINUTE SPEAKING FOR. EACH
SET OF- FOR EACH WITNESS BUT
THERE WILL BE AMPLE TIME
HOPEFULLY FOR SOME DISCUSSION
AND FEEDBACK HERE AS WELL- WE
HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN MINUTES HERE
FOR THIS UPCOMING PANEL UP WE'RE
GOING TO. TRY TO HIT OUR- OUR
BENCHMARKS BUT I WANT TO GIVE
ADEQUATE FLEXIBILITY TO THE
ADMINISTRATION I KNOW THAT- I
THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE A MAN
AMONG THE HANS HANSEN. WITH IT
IS THE DEPUTY SECRETARY CLIMATE
. AT THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AND THEN
THERE'S NEW IN TARA KEY WHO IS
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENCE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
AND THEY'VE BEEN SELECTED BY.
THE GOVERNOR'S CALIFORNIA
EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN- FOR
PRESENTATION BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE TO TALK US THROUGH
SOME OF THESE ISSUES. AND- YEAH
WE APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS NOT-
THERE'S NO SORT OF FORMAL NOTICE
AND COMMENT PERIOD- BUT THAT
THIS. THIS PROCESS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WILL HOPEFULLY GIVE
THE PUBLIC AND THE LEGISLATURE
SOME DEEPER INSIGHT INTO HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION'S HOPING TO
PURSUE THIS MATTER- SO I WANT TO
WELCOME. MISS HANSEN AND MISS-
IS KEY TO THE PANEL AND YOU CAN
TAKE IT AWAY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE INTRODUCTION
FOR ORGANIZING THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. MY NAME
IS AMANDA HANSEN AND I SERVED AS
A DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE AT THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY. HELLO I AM NEW
IN TORQUAY AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH AND I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL
TO BE HERE BOTH TO LEARN FROM
ALL THE SPEAKERS EXPERIENCE AND
EXPERTISE AND TO ALSO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN. A
DRAFT OF THIS PLAN WAS RELEASED
ON JANUARY TENTH. AND IT
OUTLINES A STRATEGIC AND
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF ACTIONS
STATE ACTIONS TO ADAPT AND BUILD
RESILIENCE TO EXTREME HEAT. I'M
GOING TO PROVIDE SOME BACKGROUND
ON THE PROCESS AND PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT UNDERTAKEN TO DEVELOP
THE DRAFT AND THEN YOU WOULD
TARA WILL THEN DETAIL HOW THAT
PUBLIC INPUT. TRULY GUIDED OUR
APPROACH AND OUR NEXT STEPS.
NEXT SLIDE. SO CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES NATURAL SYSTEMS AND
ECONOMY ARE ALREADY BEING
IMPACTED BY RISING TEMPERATURES
AS OUTLINED IN SOME OF. THE
SPEAKERS BEFORE ME TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WAS THE HOTTEST SUMMER ON
RECORD IN CALIFORNIA. YEAH BALLY
HIT ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
DEGREES IN JULY SETTING A WORLD
RECORD FOR THE HOTTEST MEASURE
TEMPERATURE IN HISTORY. AND
FRESNO SAW OVER SIXTY DAYS ABOUT
A HUNDRED DEGREES. CALIFORNIA'S
FOURTH CLIMATE CHANGE ASSESSMENT
PROJECTS THIS TREND WILL
CONTINUE. EVIDENCE IN EACH OF
THE REGIONAL REPORTS EVERY
CORNER OF THE STATE WILL
EXPERIENCE HIGHER AVERAGE
TEMPERATURES AND MORE FREQUENT
AND EXTREME HEAT EVENTS.
CALIFORNIA'S DAILY MAXIMUM
AVERAGE TEMPERATURE IS EXPECTED
TO INCREASE UP TO NEARLY SIX
DEGREES FAHRENHEIT BY TWENTY
FIFTY. NINE DEGREES FAHRENHEIT
SENATOR STERN ELOQUENTLY
EXPLAINED IN HIS OPENING REMARKS
AS AS DID OTHERS WE KNOW EXTREME
HEAT POSES PROFOUNDLY
DISPROPORTIONATE CONSEQUENCES
FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE AMONG
US. AGING POPULATIONS IN
CHILDREN PREGNANT PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC ILLNESSES
ARE EPECIALLY SENSITIVE TO HEAT
EXPOSURE. COMBINING THESE
CHARACTERISTICS AN EXISTING
HEALTH INEQUITIES WITH
ADDITIONAL FACTORS SUCH AS
POVERTY OR HOUSING INSECURITY
CAN PUT INDIVIDUALS AT
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH RISK. OF
HEAT RELATED ILLNESS AND DEATH.
FIVE THE THROUGHOUT MOST OF LAST
YEAR THE RESOURCES AGENCY AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH CO
COORDINATED THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE ADAPTATION
STRATEGY. THANKS TO THIS
STRATEGY ARE REQUIRED EVERY
THREE YEARS AND PROVIDED A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A STEP BACK
AND THINK THROUGH OUR APPROACH
INCLUDING THROUGH IDENTIFYING
WHETHER AND WHERE WE MAY HAVE
GAPS. AND THE NEED FOR AN UP TO
DATE APPROACH TO EXTREME HEAT
WAS IDENTIFIED EARLY ON. WE
COMMITTED TO UPDATING AND
EXPANDING THE STATE'S TWENTY
THIRTEEN REPORT ON EXTREME HEAT.
CALL PREPARING CALIFORNIA FOR
EXTREME HEAT GUIDANCE AND
RECOMMENDATIONS NEXT FIVE. WE
WORK WITH PARTNERS ACROSS THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BUILD A
STRATEGIC AND COMPREHENSIVE SET
OF STATE ACTIONS TO ADAPT AND
BUILD RESILIENCE TO EXTREME
HEAT. INCLUDING THE COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE HERE WITH US TODAY ALONG
WITH THOSE IN AGENCIES YOU SEE
LISTED ON THE SLIDE. AD MORE-
THIS APPROACH REALLY REFLECTS
OUR ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT
TO ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE
LIKE THE CRISIS THAT IT IS
WORKING ACROSS ALL AGENCIES TO
BREAK DOWN SILOS. TO DRAW
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN SECTORS TO
DEVELOP A DIVERSE SUITE OF
ACTIONS NEXT FIVE. THE DRAFT
EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN WAS
DEVELOPED THROUGH EXTENSIVE
PUBLIC INPUT OVER THE COURSE OF
LAST YEAR. WE HELD TEN REGIONAL
WORKSHOPS WE HAVE NUMEROUS
CONSULTATIONS WITH CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES AND WE
HELD IN EXTREME HEAT WORKSHOP
SERIES. EACH OF THE WORKSHOPS WE
INVITED SPEAKERS FROM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA TO SHARE CASE
STUDIES. BEST PRACTICES AND
STORIES ABOUT COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE. PROVIDED UPDATES ON
HOW THE INPUT WE WERE GATHERING
WITH SHAPING THE ACTION PLAN.
AND WE INVITED PARTICIPANTS TO
SHARE MORE ABOUT THEIR
PRIORITIES FOR ACTION. WE FELT
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO COME HERE
TODAY AND TO SHARE WITH YOU. TWO
KEY FINDINGS THAT EMERGED FROM
IT THIS EXPERIENCE. AND HOW
THOSE FINDINGS FROM THE PUBLIC
INPUT WE RECEIVE REALLY SHAPED
THE DRAFT STRUCTURE AND CONTENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF MY DAD
AND AS A MOTHER JUST OUTLINED
I'M GOING TO. COVER THOSE TO
KEEP FINDINGS THAT INFORM AND
SHAPE ACTION PLAN. SO THE FIRST-
WAS AT THE BEGINNING OF EACH
WORKSHOPS AND IN ALL TEN OF OUR
STATE CLIMATE ADAPTATION
STRATEGY REGIONAL WORKSHOPS THAT
AMONG THE MENTIONED. WE ASKED
PARTICIPANTS HOW EXTREME HEAT
IMPACTED THEM THEIR COMMUNITY
AND THEIR REGIONS AND WHAT
EMERGED WAS A SUITE OF PROMINENT
THEMES FROM THE HUNDREDS. OF
RESPONSES THAT WERE SHARED- IS
EXTREME SEVERELY IMPACT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND EXACERBATE
EXISTING INEQUITIES. IT
INCREASES THE THREATS OF
WILDFIRES DROUGHT AND POOR AIR
QUALITY AND BURDENS ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE IT HAS ECONOMIC
COSTS INCLUDING DISRUPTIONS TO
SUPPLY CHAINS AND HE INDUSTRIES.
AND THREATENS THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF OUR NATURAL
SYSTEMS. THE SECOND FINDING THAT
EMERGE FROM OUR PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT RELATES TO THE
STATE'S ROLE IN ADDRESSING
EXTREME HEAT. AND WE ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS IN EACH
WORKSHOP AND MAJOR THEMES THAT
EMERGED HELPED US DEVELOP BRANDS
RECOMMENDED ACTIONS. OR AREAS
WERE STATE ACTION WAS IDENTIFIED
AS MOST USEFUL INCLUDING ONE
DRIVING COORDINATION AND
COLLABORATION BOTH ACROSS LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT AND WITH OTHER
ENTITIES SUCH AS UTILITIES THE
PRIVATE SECTOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFITS AND
BEYOND. THE SECOND IS SUPPORTING
LOCAL CLIMATE ADAPTATION ACTION
THROUGH FINDING OPPORTUNITIES
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ACROSS
CALL FOR ACTION TRACKS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE ACTION PLANS
WELCOME TO THOSE IN JUST A
SECOND. THIRD OKAY. APPROACH TO
EXTRA HEAT ACT THAT DRIVES A THE
UNIT NEED RIGHT AND ACT OPINION
. AND ANY DEPRIVE ACTIONS THAT
DOUBLE MOLD BENEFITS IN ADDITION
TO REDUCING HEAT REST ACTIONS
THAT ADDRESS THIS CLIMATE RIGHT
CAN ALSO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS INCREASE PUBLIC HEALTH
PROVIDE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND
INCREASED ACCESS TO MAJOR. SO
BUILDING ON THE EXTENSIVE IN BUT
WE RECEIVED OVER THE COURSE OF
LAST YEAR WE STRUCTURED THE
PLANNED AROUND FOR ACTION TRACKS
BASED ON ALL THIS ON THE
WORKSHOP SERIES AND THE
ENGAGEMENT WE OUTLINED ABOUT
BEFORE. THE TRACKS HERE ARE
LISTED ON THE SCREEN BUT THEY
ARE TO BUILD PUBLIC AWARENESS
AND NOTIFICATION STRENGTHENING
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND RESPONSE
INCREASED THE RESILIENCE OF OUR
BUILT ENVIRONMENT AND UTILIZED
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS. UNDER
EACH ACTION TRACK THEIR
CONSISTENT TO DIFFERENT SECTIONS
THE FIRST ARE ESTABLISHED
ACTIONS WHICH TELL THE STORY OF
I'M GOING STATE ACTIONS RELATED
TO EXTREME HEAT. THOSE ESTABLISH
ACTIONS CALLED FOR IN THE TWENTY
THIRTEEN REPORT INCLUDING THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THE SECOND
ARE RECOMMENDED ACTIONS WHICH
ADDRESS IMPORTANT NEEDS FOR
STRENGTHENING RESILIENCE TO
EXTREME HEAT. AND WE CONSIDER
ALL ACTIONS RECOMMENDED BY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. IN
DEVELOPING THE DRAFT. AND WE
ALSO HOPE THE ACT PLAN ROTH THE
WE HONOR. AS THE STATE BY JUST
PRIORITY AND YOUR LEADERS ON AND
HE- INCLUDING MANY OF THE POINTS
THAT WE HEARD THE OPENING
REMARKS HERE TODAY. INCLUDE
TURNING UP AND- STATEWIDE
RESPONSE AN EXTREME HEAT ACROSS
ALL OF CAL. ENSURING INVESTMENTS
IN EXTREME HEAT ACTIONS
PRIORITIZE THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THIRD PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT THE
TRIBAL LOCAL AND REGIONAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKS FORWARD TO
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
FINALIZE AND IMPLEMENT THE
EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN. BUT WE
ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO BUILDING ON
LAST YEAR'S INVESTMENTS IN
EXTREME HEAT WHICH INCLUDE A
SUITE OF INVESTMENTS INCLUDING
URBAN AND COMMUNITY FORESTRY
AND- RAINING. A NEW COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE AND HE RAN IN OUR
OFFICE THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTERS AND
INVESTMENTS IN THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM WE ALSO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON PROGRAMMING THE
EXTREME HEAT. OUTSIDE SO TO WRAP
I WANTED JUST QUICK GO OVER OUR
NAY STEPS AND TRY. THE LAST WEEK
WE KNOW THE FINAL PUBLIC
WORKSHOP OUR EXT HEAT SERIES
ASSEMBLY INPUT ON THE- WE WERE
FEEDBACK FROM ABOUT I'M TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PARTISAN. AND
ARE CURRENTLY PROCESS WHAT WE
SHARE I'M GOING FINALLY THE PLAN
THIS. IN ADDITION TO. THE FINAL
EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLANS
FEEDBACK ON THE DRAFT WILL HELP
SHAPE OUR PROPOSAL TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE SPRING FOR
INVESTING THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THE SENATE SIDE IT
WAS INCLUDED AS PART OF THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PACKAGE AND
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. TO ADDRESS
EXTREME HEAT. I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW THE PROP ON THE HEAT ACTION
WILL BE TRACKED THROUGH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT ADAPTATION
STRATEGIES AND IMPLEMENTATION
REPORTING PROCESS. AND WITH THAT
I WANT TO THANK YOU MANY CHAIRS
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DEPUTY
SECRETARY AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR WE
DO APPRECIATE. YOUR TESTIMONY-
HOW DEFERRED IF ANY OF MY FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
INITIAL QUESTIONS- I KNOW I HAVE
A FEW BUT I'LL I'LL KICK IT TO
YOU ALL. FIRST IF YOU'D LIKE AND
I ALSO WANT TO WELCOME CENTER TO
MOAN TO. TO THE COMMITTEE- THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. BUT ANYONE
IS ONE WANT TO CHIME IN WITH
I'VE GOT A FEW. OKAY I'LL START
I'LL JUST START REAL QUICKLY
HERE- THE TIMELINE FOR FINAL
COMMENTS ON THIS I KNOW IT'S NOT
A FORMAL PERIOD BUT- IT'S THE
MIDDLE OF FEBRUARY IS THAT
CORRECT. LAST WHEN THE LAST
COUPLE WEEKS GIVE A DATE ON THAT. SENATOR STERN AT. THE APPROACH
THAT WE TOOK TO RECEIVING PUBLIC
FEEDBACK ON THE DRAFT ACTION
PLAN WAS TO UTILIZE OUR EXTREME
HEAT WORKSHOP SERIES. SO THAT
YOU KNOW WE WELCOME PEOPLE
PROVIDING INPUT ON THE- THE
DRAFT WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
GOING THROUGH WHAT WE HEARD. AND
ARE. THANK YOU SEE YOU'RE STILL
GOING THROUGH THOSE COMMENTS YOU
RECEIVED A BUNCH INPUT AT THAT
WORKSHOP THAT THOSE ONE FIFTY
COMMENTS OKAY. SO NO CONCLUSIONS
YET FROM THE FEEDBACK YOU
RECEIVED I MEAN WHAT WOULD YOU
JUST IF YOU WERE TO
CHARACTERIZE- THE RANGE OF
ISSUES AYE THE ONE THING WE'VE
HEARD IS A COMMITTEE I THINK AS
WE'VE EXPLORED AND TALK SOME OF
THE SAME STAKEHOLDERS WILL BE
HEARING FROM. BUT EVERYONE WANTS
MORE DETAIL AND THEY WANT THE
ACTION PLAN TO BE AS ACTIONABLE
AS POSSIBLE AND I KNOW THAT'S
PART OF THE PROCESS. OF MAKING
THE FRAME RATE- AND SORT OF
GETTING YOUR SCIENCE BASIS FOR
IT ALL RIGHT AND PUTTING.
PUTTING A STRUCTURE IN PLACE BUT
I THINK THAT THE- THE GOOD
FRUSTRATION THAT I'VE HEARD OUT
THERE IS THAT. PEOPLE JUST WANT
MORE DETAIL WHETHER IT'S
FOCUSING ON PUBLIC HEALTH
WEATHER IS THE SPECIFICS THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE GOING TO
NEED FOR. GETTING THEIR
SPECIFIC- ARMS MOVING INTO THIS
SPACE AND GETTING THEIR PLANS
EFFECTUATED- YOU KNOW THERE
WE'VE BEEN WORKING. WITH NOT
JUST ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS WHO
WERE HER STATEMENT READ EARLIER
BUT- SOME ERROR SEE A AND A
SIMILAR ROBERT RIVAS IS WELL AND
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER ON-
ON SOME OF THE RATING SYSTEMS
AND WAYS TO DO- HEAT WAVE EVENTS
SO WE APPRECIATE SOME OF THAT.
FOCUS ON EDUCATION. AND SORT OF
AN OUTWARD FACING PUBLIC
AWARENESS COMPONENT- I WAS
ENCOURAGED TO SEE HE HAS SOME OF
THE ELEMENTS FOCUSING ON I. HSS
WAYS TO USE OUR CARE WORK FORCE.
I THINK THAT'S A REALLY RIGHT
AND IF I WERE TO SAY THERE'S ONE
LANE THAT I'M TRYING TO. MAKE
SURE IS CARVED OUT IN ALL OF
THIS IS JUST WHAT WE CAN DO IN
THE HOME I KNOW THERE'S A-
THERE'S A LOT OF EFFORT AND WE
WANT TO SEE RESILIENCE HUBS BE
BUILT- WE WANT TO SEE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BACKSTOPS. WE
WANT COOL BUILDINGS IN SERVICES
AND I THINK THAT HAVE TO BE THE
OVER ARCHING RESILIENCE
FRAMEWORK BUT- MY INITIAL
QUESTION FOR YOU ALL WITH JUST.
HOW DO YOU SEE HE IN THE HOME
BEING A PART OF THIS FRAMEWORK
FOR ESPECIALLY FOR THE PEOPLE
DURING THOSE EVENTS THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO MOVE- YOU KNOW MY
EXPERIENCE IS GOING THROUGH.
THESE HEAT WAVES IS THE- YOU
KNOW THE MOST ON THE PEOPLE THE
PEOPLE WHO YOU REALLY DON'T WANT
TO GO GET IN THE CAR OR HAVE TO
WORK ACROSS A- LONG PARKING LOT
YOU KNOW WALKING WITH. YOU KNOW
120 DEGREES HE WITH MY- PREGNANT
WIFE ACROSS- EVEN JUST LIKE. THE
SMALL PARKING STRUCTURE OF
BLACKTOP YOU KNOW YOU EVEN IN
THAT THAT DID A MOMENT YOU
YOU'RE THINKING IS THIS GOING TO
TRIGGER SOMETHING. AND IT'S
THOSE EXPERIENCES OF MOVING
YOURSELF ACROSS. SPECIALTIES
LARGE URBAN INTERFACES THAT GETS
COMPLICATED OBVIOUSLY AND
FARMWORKER COMMUNITIES OR OTHER
RURAL AREAS IT'S A DIFFERENT
PUZZLE BUT- CAN YOU JUST COMMENT
A LITTLE BIT ON. EXTREME HEAT.
AND IN THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT BUT
THIS BUT SPECIFICALLY IN
PEOPLE'S HOMES SO BOTH MULTI
FAMILY. AND IN HOMES. WHAT WHAT
CAN WE DO TO IDENTIFY THOSE
POPULATIONS BETTER WHO NEEDS
HELP. AND WHAT TOOLS DO WE HAVE
FOR THEM TO MITIGATE THAT RISK
WITHOUT LEAVING THEIR HOUSE.
THANKS I'LL TAKE A FIRST CUT IN
AND OPEN TO DOING TARA I THINK.
THAT I AM NOT GOING TO COMMENT
ON WHAT WE HAVE IN PLACE TO
IDENTIFY THOSE FOLKS I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT- YOU KNOW THAT
PROBABLY FALLS INTO THE CATEGORY
OF. WORK THEIR COLLEAGUES THAT
CAL YES. I DO AND DO WELL BUT I
WILL SAY THAT THE FOCUS ON
PEOPLE'S HOMES IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE ADMINISTRATION-
THERE'S A SUITE OF PROPOSALS.
RECOMMENDED ACTIONS IN THE DRAFT
ACTION PLAN- AND IT'S HELPFUL TO
HEAR THAT IS AN IMPORTANT AREA
OF FOCUS FOR YOU ALL BECAUSE- AS
WE NOTED YOU DON'T WORK WE'RE
LISTENING TO FEEDBACK AND WE'RE
DOING OUR VERY BEST TO
INCORPORATE IT- YOU KNOW WE'VE-
MADE VERY CLEAR IN OUR PROPOSAL
LAST YEAR THAT. THE FUNDING FOR
LIFE WHICH WAS INTENDED TO AND
IN AREAS THAT WERE AVAILABLE TO
EXTREME HEAT. TO DO THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY UPGRADES TO PEOPLE'S
HOMES IN A WAY THAT UTILIZES. AT
FOR EXAMPLE- HEAT PUMPS SUCH
THAT PEOPLE CAN HAVE ACCESS BOTH
THE HEAT AND ADD TO AIR
CONDITIONING WHEN NECESSARY- WE
HAVE A- ROBUST FOR. THE EXISTING
CLIMATE CHANGE BUDGET FOCUSED ON
SCALING AT THE DISSEMINATION OF
HEAT PUMPS. INTO WELCOME
COMMUNITIES AND THE FOCUS ON
WHERE PEOPLE. IS AND CENTER FOR
US SO WE WENT OUT BY MISTAKE.
ONE THING I WOULD ADD THAT IS
THIS TO THAT ACT THAT ARE THAT
AMOUNT JUST WENT THROUGH- IN
TERMS OF INVEST IN BILL THIS AND
- WE THE IN HOME IS WHILE WE
ARE- ALSO VERY FOCUSED. THAT IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES- AND
THE SUPPORT SYSTEMS AB THAT ALSO
NEED TO BE IN PLACE AND
ESPECIALLY THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
TARGET THOSE TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES- SO THAT IS
DEFINITELY A PRIORITY FOR US AND
IS REFLECTED THROUGHOUT THE
ACTION PLAN BUT ABSOLUTELY
LOOKING FORWARD TO. CONTINUED
INPUT AND DISCUSSION ON. WAYS
WHERE WE CAN BE PROVIDING. THAT
SUPPORT. COMMUNITIES PEOPLE.
THANKS FOR THE FEEDBACK AND I
KNOW WE'LL DIG INTO A NUMBER OF
OTHER ISSUES I APPRECIATE YOU-
DELVING INTO THAT ONE ELEMENT
THIS IS A MULTI HEADED HYDRA
THIS HEAT EPIDEMIC- BUT- WILL
DIG DEEPER IN IF ANY OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE WANT TO KEEP THINGS
MOVING IF YOU ALL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION I KNOW YOU WILL
BE HAVE SOME REPRESENTATIVES AS
WELL ON THE LAST PANEL BUT- I'M
HOPEFULLY TODAY'S HEARING ALSO
HELPS. ELEVATE SOME OF THESE
FEEDBACK FOR YOU SO YOU CAN
INFORM YOUR DECISION AND WE CAN
HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT NOT JUST
THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION ALSO
FROM LAST YEAR BUT LOOKING
FORWARD WE KNOW THIS IS AN
ELEMENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
CURRENT BUDGET AS WELL AND WE'LL
LET THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES TO
DIG DEEPER INTO THE NUMBERS BUT-
WE DO APPRECIATE YOU PUTTING
THIS FORWARD AND WORKING WITH
OUR COMMITTEE- WITH THAT. LET'S
LET'S TURN TO OUR SECOND PANEL-
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT THE
HUMAN COST OF HEAT. SPECIFICALLY
IN THE RISK AND VULNERABILITY
THAT. A DEPUTY DIRECTOR KEY WAS
TALKING ABOUT AT THE END THERE
WITH. DEPUTY SECRETARY HANSON IN
TERMS OF IDENTIFYING POPULATIONS
AND REALLY TRYING TO MEET THEM
WHERE THEY ARE- SO FIRST UP. WE
HAVE. I SHALL DESCRIBE ALL THE
WITNESSES JUST AT THE GATES AND
THEN AND THEN I'LL INTRODUCE OUR
FIRST WITNESS. SO- LET ME GO
THROUGH. SO IN THIS IN THIS
HUMAN IMPACTS PANEL WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR FROM A NUMBER OF EXPERTS
SOME OF WHOM HAVE GONE SO FAR AS
BUILDING THE MODELS TO ACTUALLY
IDENTIFY THESE IMPACTS OR- LOOK
AT THE EVERYTHING DOWN FROM IN
HOME COOLING TO COOL ROOF AND
WALL PERFORMANCE OF LAWRENCE
BERKELEY LABS- WOMAN WHO
ACTUALLY HAS BEEN A WAREHOUSE
WORKER AT AMAZON IS GOING
THROUGH OUR OWN VERY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH HEAT-
REPRESENTATIVE A ROOM IMPORTANT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
THAT. LOOKING AT WHAT THE REAL
IN IMPASSES ARE IN PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH WORKERS AND COMMUNITIES I
COUNTY REPRESENTED TO GIVE US
SOME INSIGHT ON HOW
VULNERABILITY MAPPING IS
ACTUALLY GETTING MORE GRANULAR
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL AND BUILT
INTO THEIR SUSTAINABILITY PLANS
BUT TO START OFF WE WANT TO GO
TO JONATHAN PARR FREE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CLIMATE RESOLVE. WHO
HAS BEEN MY HEAT EVANGELIST AND
TURN ME AND MY EYES AND IN MY
WORK ON CLIMATE ADVOCACY
SQUARELY ON THIS ISSUE AND WE'RE
DEEPLY INDEBTED TO HIM FOR
GETTING HIS INCREDIBLE
ORGANIZATION TO NOT JUST
ADVOCATE BUT BACK IT UP WITH
REAL SCIENCE AND REAL POLICY SO
MISS PARKER YOU WANNA KICK
THINGS OFF FOR US AND GIVE US A
LITTLE OVERVIEW HERE ON. ON THIS
THIS VERY HUMAN COST. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATORS. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE A
GREETINGS FROM DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES. YOU KNOW PSYCHOLOGISTS
SAY THAT AN AUDIENCE CAN ONLY
RETAIN ONE OR TWO ITEMS FROM THE
SPEECH AND SO WITH THAT IN MIND.
I'M JUST GOING FOR ONE THE
CONCEPT WHICH I THINK IS AT THE
HEART. OF CALIFORNIA'S EXTREME
HEAT EMERGENCY. ACCORDING TO THE
RENOWNED HEAT SCIENTISTS HERSHAM
ON HARI. THE EARTH. IN ITS PRE
INDUSTRIAL STATE REFLECTED ABOUT
ONE THIRD OF THE SUN'S ENERGY
INTO SPACE AND IN TECHNICAL
TERMS. POINT THREE THREE S. R.
SOLAR REFLECTANCE. ZOOM AHEAD TO
TODAY AND THE WAY THAT WE'VE
BUILT OUR CITIES AND CON TOWARD
OUR LANDSCAPE. WHICH HAS
PROFOUNDLY REDUCED- THE EARTH'S
SOLAR REFLECTANCE IN. CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE ABOUT WORK. HUNDRED
MILLION LANE MILES OF ROADS IN
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE
ROADS. ARE COVERED IN BLACK
ASPHALT. ASPHALT HAS A SOLAR
REFLECTANCE OF. POINT. ZERO
FIVE. IT'S SO HOUSEHOLD IS TIMES
MORE- SO. OF THIS. THEN THE ****
REFLECTED WOULD BE AN ****
ABSORBS SUN'S DURING THE DAY AND
RELEASE IT. INTO NAY AT NIGHT
AND DR TELL US THAT THE HUMAN
BODY NEEDS TIME AT NIGHT TO
RECOVER FROM THE DAY'S EXPOSURE
TO EXTREME HEAT AND YET THE WAY
WE BUILT OUR CITIES AND ROOFTOPS
IT ROBS MANY CALIFORNIANS OF.
THAT ABILITY TO RECOVER.
CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS TWELVE
MILLION HOMES IN THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE HOMES ARE
COVERED WITH ASPHALT SHINGLES
THAT ABSORBS THE SUN'S ENERGY
AND VENTILATE THROUGH INTO THE
LIVING QUARTERS. SO LEGISLATORS
IT'S WITHIN YOUR POWER TO HELP
STOP CALIFORNIA FROM BEING SO
MALADAPTIVE. NEW MODERN SOCIETY
WE DID IT WITH THE BEST
INTENTIONS BUT IT IS A VAST
GEOENGINEERING EXPERIMENTS THAT
WE NEED TO FIX- WE NEED TO
CORRECT OUR BUILT ENVIRONMENTS
AND WE TURN OUR CITIES TO THE
CORRECT BALANCE OF REFLECTING
SUNLIGHT. THANKFULLY WE HAVE
TOOLS THAT WE CAN USE TO CALL
CALIFORNIA. ONE AGREES HAS BEEN
WERE WITH THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IN OUR ORGANIZATION CAN
TAKE SOME SMALL CREDIT FOR THE
CITY NOW HAVING OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND RUPEES THANK USE
REFLECTIVE SHINGLES AND OVER A
HUNDRED CITY BLOCKS THAT NOW
HAVE COLD PAVEMENT AND OVER
SIXTY. LA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT PLAYGROUNDS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE COOLER MORE COLORFUL
BY COVERING ASPHALT WITH REALLY
COOL MATERIALS. IMPORTANT STUDY
BY UCLA'S IN THE GOOS MON FOUND
THAT HI EL MEDIO STRATEGY
REFLECTING SUNLIGHT COUPLED WITH
MORE TREES COULD REDUCE AIR
TEMPERATURES BY THREE POINT SIX
DEGREES FAHRENHEIT ENOUGH TO
MAKE A LIFE OR DEATH DIFFERENCE
FOR HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE. AND THIS
STRATEGY COULD ALSO DELAY THE
WARMING EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE IN LOS ANGELES FOR TWENTY
FIVE TO SIXTY YEARS SO SENATORS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND YOU
HAVE THE YOU CAN HELP REBALANCE
THE STATE'S SOLAR REFLECTIVE
BUDGET. AND HELP WITH THAT
BROADER TASK OF COOLING BY
BRINGING PRE HAZARD MITIGATION
FOCUS TO FUNDING RESILIENCE.
HUBS BEING ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER
IN OUR ESPECIALLY IN OUR-
INCREASE CAL OSHA'S IN. STAFF
PROTECT WORKERS IN BY TASK LOCAL
HEALTH TO DO JOB OF GATHERING
DATA ON HEAT RELATED DEATH AND
HOSPITALIZATION. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EXTREME HEAT
ACTION PLAN IT'S BEEN A
FANTASTIC START JUST AMAZING AND
ALSO MAJOR THANKS GOES TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LUIS REDRESS FOR
CHANTING SUCH COOL SOLUTIONS.
AND YET. WITH THE STATE'S
APPROACH IN ITS FRAMEWORK IT'S
KIND OF A SO MUCH IS THERE IT'S
AN ALPHABET SOUP IT'S A LOT TO
MANAGE AND WITH AN ALPHABET SOUP
IT IS WITHIN YOUR LEGISLATIVE-
KARONGA. TO ARRANGE THOSE
ALPHABET PIECES INTO WORDS
PARAGRAPHS AND LEGISLATION AND
TO FORM A REALLY INTEGRATED AND
EFFECTIVE COOLING PROGRAM AT THE
STATE AND I HOPE WILL BREAK CASF. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR CHEN
IN THE CHOI. MISTER PAR FREE-
NEXT UP I WANT TO WELCOME
KRISTIN TAURUS CALLING- WHO IS
LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SUSTAINABILITY DIRECTOR- AND HAS
PUT A HEARD LABORING OVER INTO
THE WATER ON BUILDING
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN AND- KALD R.
COUNTY THAT THEY REALLY EMERGE
FROM A TWENTY NINETEEN DOCUMENT
BUT IS TAKING SHAPE IN BEEN.
DRILLING DOWN ON THIS ISSUE EVER
SINCE- THIS POLLING DO YOU WANT
TO. OFFER LITTLE INSIGHT FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE STATE'S
LAREST COUNTY. YES CERTAINLY
THANK YOU CHAIR STERN. THANKS
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
GREETINGS ON VICE CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- LIKE THE
SENATOR SIGNED MY NAME IS
KRISTEN BORIS CALLING HIM A
SUSTAINABILITY PROGRAM DIRECTOR
THE COUNTY CHIEF SUSTAINABILITY
OFFICE AND- VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY DISCUSS WHAT OUR
TEAM CALLED THE SILENT KILLER.
AT EXTREME HEAT. THE LAST YEAR I
TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
TO DISCUSS WHAT WAS OPPENHEIMER
FORTHCOMING VOTER ASSESSMENT.
WHICH EXAMINES COMMUNITY SCALE
CLIMATE VULNERABILITIES FOR ALL
CORNERS OF LA. WE'VE SINCE
COMPLETED THAT ASSESSMENT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SEVERAL OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS HERE TODAY AND
I'LL SHARE OUR FINDINGS RELATED
TO EXTREME HEAT. SO EXTREME HEAT
WILL HAVE WIDESPREAD EFFECTS ON
PEOPLE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
INCREASING BOTH IN FREQUENCY AND
SEVERITY ACROSS L. A. COUNTY
WITH UP TO A TEN FOLD INCREASE.
IN THE OCCURRENCE OF HEAT WAVES
BY MID CENTURY. WE EXPECTS THE
LARGEST INCREASES IN EXTREME
HEAT IN THE SANTA CLARITA AND
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. NO EXTREME
HEAT CAN JEOPARDIZE PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH IN MANY WAYS JUST
SOME EXAMPLES WORSENING
RESPIRATORY AND HEART CONDITIONS
AND THAT'S WHY WE AS A COUNTY
TAKE THIS ISSUE SERIOUSLY. THE
NEXT THING HE WILL ALSO HAVE
MONUMENTAL AND COMPLEX IMPACTS
WERE ENERGY SYSTEM AND OTHER
PIECES OF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SAME GONNA FOCUS ON OUR SOCIAL
VULNERABILITIES TO EXTREME HEAT
IN OTHER WORDS THE PEOPLE WHO
WILL BE MOST DISTRESSED BY
EXTREME HEAT. TO DO THAT WE
CONSIDERED IN OUR REPORT TWENTY
NINE SOCIAL FACTORS WHICH WE
CROSSWALKS WITH CLIMATE DATA AT
THE CENSUS TRACTS FAILED TO
IDENTIFY COMMUNITIES OF CONCERN
FOR EXTREME HEAT. WE ARE HIGHLY
CONCERNED ABOUT COMMUNITIES LIKE
RECEITA AND WINNETKA IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. SHOP HIGH
PROPORTIONS OF LIMITED ENGLISH
HOUSEHOLDS IN PEOPLE WITH PRE
EXISTING HEALTH CONDITIONS. OUR
REPORT ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
MONTEBELLO. WHICH IS AT RISK OF
EXPOSURE TO EXTREME HEAT PLUS.
COPULATION IS MADE UP OF A HIGH
PROPORTION OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THE VEHICLE
ACCESS. WE ALSO LIFT UP HE'S
STILL LAYING IN SOUTH EAST LA
WHERE URBAN HEAT ISLAND EFFECT
CAN MAGNIFY IMPACTS EVEN WHEN
THERE IS MODEST INCREASES IN
REGIONAL TEMPERATURE. THE REPORT
MAKES CLEAR THAT THERE'S A
DISTINCTLY RACIALIZED ASPECTS TO
CLIMB UPON ABILITIES IN MANY
CASES. THE FOR EXTREME HEAT WE
FOUND THAT LATINOS MAKE UP 49%
OF LA COUNTY'S POPULATION THAT
ENGINE UNITY IS WITH HIGHLY WITH
HIGH **** ABILITY TO EXTREME
HEAT. WE HAVE SIXTY SEVEN. OF
THE POPULATION. SO THAT MEANS
BUT THEN ALSO BEAR THE BRUNT OF
EXTREME HEAT- IMPACTS. SUCH AS
PRETERM BIRTH. NOT IN MY IS A
STRIKE. AND JUST. A BUT NOT
EXACTLY YOU NOT SURPRISING
FINDING. OUR ASSESSMENT WAS THAT
A CHECK OF SUCH LIKE HAVE A FULL
SUITE OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO MAKE
YOUR FOR YOU TODAY. INSTEAD WE
SIMPLY WANT TO RAISE THE ALARM
ABOUT THE INCREASING LIKELIHOOD
OF EXTREME HEAT EMERGENCIES AND
ASSURE THAT THERE ARE LITERALLY
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIKELY TO BE VULNERABLE TO BEES
AND OTHER CRIME IN EMERGENCIES
IN L. A. ALONE. FURTHER DOWN THE
AGENDA OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
MCALLEN LEADS ARE OFFICE OF
EVERITT MANAGEMENT. HE'LL GO
INTO FURTHER EXTREME HEAT
EMERGENCY WORK THAT THE COUNTY
CONDUCTS THANK YOU- THANK YOU
MISTER IS CALLING- IN FOR ALL
YOUR TECHNICAL SUPPORT- AND
PUTTING A SPOTLIGHT ON OUR
COMMUNITIES- NEXT UP I WANNA
INVITE NANCY'S INIGO. I WAS
DIRECTOR OF THE WORKERS HEALTH
PROGRAM FOR YOU SEE TO TOW THE
IN THE CHRISTIANE POLITE DID
SUED THE CALIFORNIA. AND
ORGANIZATIONS BEEN PROVIDING
HEALTH AND SAFETY EDUCATION
ACCESS TO DAY LABORERS HOUSEHOLD
WORKERS WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
COMMUNITIES- SOME IS ANY GUIDE-
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY SCARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY I
PLAN TO SHARE WITH EXTREME HEAT
IN THE HOME ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE.
FOR ONE OR MORE WORKERS- MY NAME
IS NANCY SUNY NINE AS MENTIONED
I'VE LET THE WORKERS HEALTH
PROGRAM- FOR EIGHT YEARS WE
FACILITATE HEALTH AND SAFETY
TRAINING. AND SUPPORT DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS AND RECOVERY
EFFORTS FOR DALY RESENT THE
MASTIC WORKERS YES GUYS AND LOS
ANGELES BASED WORKERS CENTER
SERVING MOSTLY LATINO IMMIGRANT.
MONOLINGUAL SPANISH SPEAKERS
THAT COMMUTE ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. EXPOSURE TO
EXTREME HEAT HAS BECOME
UNFORTUNATELY PART OF THE JOB
WHERE IMMIGRANT WORKERS ARE
HAVING TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR
HEALTH AND BARELY MAKING ENDS
MEET ON MOST DAYS OF THE YEAR.
THE LEVERS DO OUTDOOR WORK LIKE
GENERAL LABOR CONSTRUCTION OR
GARDENING IN PRIVATE HOMES FOR
MINIMAL A MINIMAL IF. HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROTECTIONS DURING HOT
WEATHER EXPERIENCE WORKERS
ANTICIPATING NEEDING TO CARRY
THEIR OWN DRINKING WATER AND
SECURING WORK EARLIER IN THE
MORNINGS TO AVOID HEAT
EXHAUSTION. MANY WORKERS TAKE
THEIR OWN HEALTH AND SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS AS A RESULT THE PAST
HOSPITALIZATIONS OR GETTING
INJURED ON THE JOB OR EMPLOYERS
HAVE FAILED TO PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS. THESE IMMIGRANT
WORKERS ARE OFTEN UNINSURED AND
MORE LIKELY TO BE LIVING WITH
CHRONIC DISEASES THAT ARE OFTEN
UNTREATED MAKING SOMETHING LIKE
EXTREME HEAT A DEADLY WORK
HAZARD. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RECOMMEND THE FOLLOWING. AT
REMOVING COLUSA EXCLUSION OF
THOSE THAT WORK AND PRIVATE
HOMES DOING DOMESTIC. WORK LIKE
GARDENING AND CLEANING. THE
MASTER WORK WHETHER IT BE MAD
LABOR OR GIVING AND SOME TOLD.
REQUIRES IN AND OUTDOOR ACT.
EXTREME HEAT OFTEN. EXISTING
WORK HAZARDS DOMESTIC WORKERS
HAVE BECOME ILL WHILE GOING BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN CLEANING AND
AIR CONDITIONED WHOM AND WHILE
FAT WHILE FIRE ASHES FROM
SOMEONE'S BACK YOU. OTHER IN
ENOUGH TIME FOR WORKERS BODIES
TO FULLY ACCLIMATE TO
TEMPERATURE CHANGES. ANOTHER
CHANGE THAT IS NEEDED LANGUAGE
AND CULTURAL ACCESSIBLE
EDUCATION OUTREACH THAT MATCHES
GEOGRAPHIC IMPACT NOT ENOUGH IS
BEING DONE TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS AN INFRASTRUCTURE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING COMMUNITIES. MARKHAM
COLLABORATION WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
ETHNIC MEDIA THAT DISSEMINATES
INFORMATION ABOUT RESOURCES IS
NEEDED COMMUNICATION RELYING ON
SOCIAL MEDIA AND EMAIL DISMISSES
A LARGE PART OF THE POPULATION
THAT IS COMMUTING TO AND FROM
WORK WITH LITTLE FONG RECEPTION.
COMMUNICATION ACROSS HOTSPOTS
WHERE LOW WAGE WORKERS TRAVEL TO
AND FROM WORK ARE KEY AREAS TO
SPREAD AWARENESS OF LOCAL
RESOURCES TO PROTECT AGAINST
EXTREME HEAT. RESOURCES
INCLUDING COOLING CENTERS NEED
TO BE ALLOCATED LOCALLY AND MAP
ALONGSIDE PROJECTIONS OF WHERE
EXTREME HEAT WILL CONTINUE TO
DRASTIC RICE. LASTLY WE NEED TO
APPLY A PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH
TO EXTREME HEAT THIS APPROACH
WILL LOOK MORE CLOSELY AT HOW
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
FACTOR INTO VULNERABILITY AND
RESILIENCE WORKERS ARE AT RISK
AT WORK BUT THEY'RE ALSO NOT
FINDING RELIEF AT HOME. FOR
EXAMPLE MANY WORKERS LIVE IN
URBAN AREAS ARE ALSO VULNERABLE
TO EXTREME HEAT OFTEN LIVING IN
CROWDED OLDER BUILDINGS THAT
LACK PROPER VENTILATION. ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE AND IMMIGRATION
STATUS ALSO IMPACT THE WORKERS
ABILITY TO PREVENT HEAT ILLNESS
OR EVEN DEATH DURING EXTREME
HEAT. ON BEHALF OF THE THAT'S
KIND OF THOUSANDS OF WORKERS
THAT WE SERVE WE ASK THAT THE
BURDEN OF CLIMATE CHANGE NOT
CONTINUE TO FALL UPON ALREADY
WILL DOUBLE COMMUNITIES BUT
RATHER THAT WE WORK TOGETHER ON
A DATING AND BROADENING THE
RESPONSE TO EXTREME HEAT AND OUR
STATE. THAT TRULY RESOURCES
HIGHLY IMPACTED COMMUNITIES WE
LOOK FORWARD T CONTINUING. THIS
CONVERSATION THANK YOU- THANK
YOU MISTER MAKER- WE WILL
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION. FOR
BEING SO CONNECTED TO THE GROUND
THOUGH- LOST WELL KEEPING YOUR
HEAD ON THESE POLICY SOLUTIONS
TO MAKE IT A VERY CONCRETE WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT- NEXT UP WE
HAVE. MARIANA STRADA- WHO IS-
ACTUALLY- I'VE BEEN ONE OF THOSE
MEMBERS WORK FORCE OUT THERE.
I'M DOING THE WORK AND- I MISS
IS THAT EITHER WE APPRECIATE YOU
COMING TO US TO TELL YOUR STORY-
AND WE WELCOME YOU TO. THE JOINT
COMMITTEE. EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS MONEY AND
THE S. PLAN AND I AM A GRADUATE
STUDENT AT UCLA STUDYING URBAN
AND REGIONAL PLANNING. I ALSO
WORK WITH JONATHAN PARK FREE ACT
FINALLY RESOLVED BUT BEFORE I
WAS WITH CLAMOR RESOLVED I
WORKED AS THE- AT AN AMAZON
WAREHOUSE IN MORENO VALLEY WHICH
IS A SMALL CITY IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. AND AS A KICKER I WOULD
HAVE EXPANDED THAT TIME ME
EXACTLY WHAT ROLE AND HOW FAR
DOWN THE ROAD TO GO. TO GET THE
ITEMS FOR THE ORDER I WAS
DEALING AND LOOKING FLOOR IS
INCREDIBLY LARGE THERE MUST BE
AT LEAST A. HUNDRED ROLES THAT
WE ARE PICKING FROM. AND THE
TYPE OF CLAIM THAT AMAZON HAD.
TO US. WHEN IT COMES OF. A
COUPLE OF. ON EVERY WORLD SO
THERE WOULD BE TIMES WHEN WE
WOULD BE PICKING ITEMS. SEVERAL
MINUTES WITHOUT ANY COOLING AT
ALL. AND SINCE I WAS WORKING
THERE DURING THE SUMMER TIMES.
WHEN I WOULD CLOCK IN THE
MORNING IT WOULD ALREADY BE WARM
. AND DURING THE MIDDLE OF THE
SHIP IT WAS EVEN HOTTER- AND
THROUGHOUT THE SHIFT FOR
CONSTANTLY ON THE MOVE AND
ENCOURAGED TO MOVE FASTER IN
ORDER TO ME OUR HOURLY RATE- AND
WE'RE WALKING UP TO SEVERAL
MILES- IN THE ORKDAY AND THAT
HE EVENTUALLY STARTS TO GET TO
YOU. THE PHARMACIST AND THE
BLOWING HOT AIR BACK TO YOU
WHICH CAN FEEL WORSE AT TIMES.
AND THERE WERE MANY TIMES WHEN I
FELT SO HOT AND UNCOMFORTABLE TO
THE POINT WHERE I FELT DIZZY.
IT'S SO HOT AND YOU'RE THERE
FOR. AT LEAST TEN HOURS BECAUSE
THAT'S THE AVERAGE SHIFT TIME.
AND THE WAY I DESCRIBE THE HEAT
AT AMAZON IS IF YOU'RE IF YOU
IMAGINE YOURSELF SHOPPING AT A
WAREHOUSE TYPE OF STORES LIKE
WALMART. BUT WITH NO AIR
CONDITIONING AND YOU HAVE TO
MOVE VERY FAST AND YOU'RE STUCK
THERE FOR A VERY LONG TIME. AND
WHEN YOU START WORKING AT AMAZON
THERE ARE VIDEOS ON SAFETY THAT
YOU HAVE TO WATCH ON HOW TO PICK
UP THE BOX PROPERLY- BUT THERE
IS NO INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THE
SYMPTOMS OF HEAT ILLNESS LOOK
LIKE. OR WHAT TO DO WHEN YOU ARE
EXPERIENCING THEM ALL THE
WORKERS HAVE. ARE THOSE SMALL
FANS ON EVERY OTHER I DON'T.
THINK YOU. M. THANK YOU FOR
CONSOLIDATING WHAT'S- HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
HOURS OF EXPERIENCE INTO. THREE
SHORT MINUTES- BUT YOUR
TESTIMONY IS- MAY HAVE BEEN
BRIEF BUT IT'S WELL HEARD BY THE
COMMITTEE AND WE APPRECIATE YOU
MRS THAT OTHER- NOW WE HAVE. TO
THE LEADING EXPERTS IN THE IN
THE COUNTRY JOINING US FROM
LAWRENCE BERKELEY NATIONAL LABS-
RUNNING LEVINSON IS THE LEADER
OF THE HEAT ISLAND GROUP. AND
MAX WAY WHO- IS IT NEXT PART ON-
H. FAQ STANDARDS IN A HEAT
VULNERABILITY X. INDEX THAT HE'S
GONNA BE TALKING US THROUGH. AND
ALSO A FORMER CLASSMATE OF MINE
AND UC BERKELEY SAYS A VERY-
VERY WELCOME- PRESENCE ON OUR
PANEL HERE TO SEE- WHAT THE
SMARTEST PEOPLE I KNEW CAL
DIGGING DEEP INTO THIS COMPLEX
ISSUE. SO- MISTER LEVINSON YOU
WANT IT DOCUMENTS AND YOU WANT
TO GET STARTED HERE AND THEN
WE'LL TURN IT DR WAY. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR YEAH COMMITTEE
SPEAK TO TODAY. BOB I READ THE
HEAT ISLAND GROUP THAT WORKS
BERKELEY NATIONAL LABORATORY
WHERE WE TRY TO KEEP OUR PEOPLE
AND OUR BUILDINGS AND WHOLE
CITIES ARE COOLER IN HOT PLACES
. TODAY I'D LIKE TO SHARE THREE
POINTS THE FIRST IS THAT HEAT
ISLAND COUNTERMEASURES AND THESE
ARE STEPS LIKE USING COOL ROOFS
OR MORE RECENTLY COOL WALLS. FOR
SHADE TREES AND A NUMBER OF
OTHER THINGS OUGHT THEY WILL
PROVIDE FAIL SAFE COOLING DURING
HEATWAVES MEANING THEY DON'T
DEPEND ON THE AVAILABILITY OF
ELECTRICITY. AND THEY CAN BE
FIVE TO TEN TIMES MORE EFFECTIVE
INDOORS THAN OUTSIDE THESE
MEASURES ARE GREAT FOR LOWERING
THE OUTSIDE AIR TEMPERATURE IN
THE CITY. BUT BECAUSE THEY- ALL
THE CIRCUS OF OUR HOMES EITHER
BY REFLECTING MORE SUNLIGHT OR
PREVENTING SUNLIGHT FROM
REACHING OUR HOMES THROUGH
SHADE. THEY HAD EVEN GREATER
BENEFITS AND THIS IS A VERY
VALUABLE THING BECAUSE OUR HEAT
WAVES ARE OFTEN COINCIDENT WITH
POWER FAILURES SO- THAT IT'S THE
FIRST POINT LIKE TO SHARE. THE
SECOND IS THAT I WORK A LOT WITH
THE BUILDING STANDARDS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE TITLE
TWENTY FOUR PART SIX WHICH IS
OUR ENERGY STANDARD IN TITLE
TWENTY FOUR PART ELEVEN WHICH
USE OUR GREEN BUILDING STANDARD.
THESE ARE EXCELLENT STANDARDS-
BUT THEY FOCUS ON ENERGY SAVINGS
CARBON SAVINGS AND COST SAVINGS
ALL VERY WORTHWHILE OBJECTIVES.
BUT AS WE ARE DEVELOPING.
PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS EXTREME HEAT
THOSE NEED TO BE BASED ON HUMAN
OUTCOMES AND THAT MEANS THAT
STANDARDS NEED TO RECOGNIZE THE
VALUE OF REDUCING DEATH ILLNESS
AND MISERY. SO WE WANT TO REWARD
IMPROVEMENTS TO THERMAL COMFORT
SEVERAL SAFETY TO COMFORT AND TO
PRODUCTIVITY. AND THE FINAL
POINT IS WHILE CALIFORNIA IS IN
THE COMING YEARS GOING TO MISS
EXTENSIONAL INVESTMENTS TO
ADDRESS EXTREME HEAT THAT'S NOT
THE END OF THE STORY AND AS
CALIFORNIA MAKES INVESTMENTS IN
THESE PROGRAMS IT SHOULD
DEDICATE RESOURCES TO MONITORING
THEIR OUTCOMES. THAT IS TO SAY
WHAT'S LEARN WHAT WORKS BY
MEASURING REDUCTIONS IN
TEMPERATURE SHE STRESSED THE
ONUS HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS
AND WHAT'S- MEASURE THE
IMPROVEMENTS TO HEALTH COMFORT
PRODUCTIVITY AND LEARNING AND
THIS I THINK ARE THE WAYS THAT
WE CAN TAKE STRONG STEPS TOWARDS
DEVELOPING EXTREME HEAT
COUNTERMEASURES THAT ARE WILL
BENEFIT ALL CALIFORNIANS WILL BE
EFFECTIVE AND CAN GUIDE OUR
FUTURE INVESTMENTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU DR- NEXT UP. MISTER WAY. YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH KNOWN SENATOR STERN AND-
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ ANOTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
KIND WORDS SENATOR STERN- SO GO
GO BEARS HOLDEN HALLS. TODAY
OKAY SHARING FROM- PROJECT
CALDERON SO STANCE CALIFORNIA
KIT OR TO IT GOING UNDER
ENVIRONMENTS. AND HE- TO OKAY
WORD OF- COMMUNITY INPUT AND- S.
BELOW. THE PROJECT IS BAY IN
FRANCE. AND IS FOR ON HOMES
PRESIDENT HOME. AND HE RESULTING
TOOLKIT I DON'T. OUTPUT INCLUDE
SEVERAL AND INCLUDING SHEETS.
MODELING A COUPON IN TOOL AND
PROGRAM RIGHT. SO WE FIND
SEVERAL CHAEBOL. IN FRESNO IN ON
FRANCE WHICH ARE DE AREAS OVER
SEVENTY PER ARE UNCOMFORTABLE
HOT AT HOME VERY OFTEN DURING
THE SUMMER AND RESIDENTS ON THE
TOP FLOORS AND THOSE RESIDENTS
AND UNITSTHAT LACK AIR
CONDITIONING WHICH IS ABOUT
FIFTEEN PERCENT. ARE SPECIALLY
VULNERABLE THERE A LOT OF OLDER
INEFFICIENT AIR CONDITIONERS
THEM UP ON SOME SOFT COOLERS
WITHOUT IN UNITS WITHOUT
INTRODUCED. THE FINES MEASURE
ARE PARTICULAR AFFECTED. ON SOME
OF THE PARA MEASURE ARE STILL
HERE WINDOW. ROOF INSULATION.
AND COOL ARE TO BE THE MOST OF
PASSIVE MEASURES THAT DON'T
ENERGY- OVERALL. AND NATURAL. OR
OLD YOUR WINDOW DURING THE
EVENING. ADDRESS COOLER. IT'S
PAST FOR TOP IN THE- PLOT OF THE
- WANT TO WHEN THE- OF NEW
MEXICO TO ME. IN SOUTHWEST
FRESNO. WHILE I'M ON THE WIRES
IS A METRIC DISCOMFORT OUR AND
ON ACCESS IS EACH OF THEM. THAT
WERE MÀ. THAT'S JUST SHOWING THE
NATURAL COOL WINDOW FOR ARE. ARE
PROMISING MEASURES. SO IN TERMS
OF RECORD. THE FIRST IS THE WE
NEED MORE. EQUITABLE DEFINITIONS
FOR EXTREME HEAT AND HEAT WAVES
SO TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE WERE
A RECORD NUMBER OF DAYS GREATER
THAN A HUNDRED DEGREES
FAHRENHEIT IN FRESNO AT SIXTY
NINE WHICH EXCEEDS THE
PROJECTION FOR TWENTY FORTY
THEIR NINETEEN HUESO GREATER
THAN A HUNDRED DEGREES SHOWN
BELOW. BUT ONLY SIXTEEN OF THE
SIXTY NINE DAYS OVER CLASSIFIED
AS EXTREME HEAT DAYS BY THE
STATE'S DEFINITION OF EXTREME
HEAT AND ONLY ONE OF THE NINE
WAVES IS COUNTED AS A HEAT WAVE
USING THAT EXTREME HEAT
DEFINITION. EXTREMELY TECH
THRESHOLD IS A HUNDRED SIX
DEGREES FAHRENHEIT FRESNO
INVARIANTS BY CLIMATE IT'S BASED
ON HISTORICAL NINETIETH
PERCENTILE. LEVELS SO I THINK WE
SHOULD CONSIDER ABSOLUTE
THRESHOLDS IN ADDITION TO
LOCATION DEPENDENT THRESHOLDS
FOR EXTREME. HEAT AND HEAT WAVES
. PHAM SECONDLY WE NEED.
IMPROPER TO ENSURE ADEQUATE IN
EXISTING FOR LOW INCOME AND-
AREAS WITH PRINT. WILL BUILDING
SO THIS JUST. IS SHOWING ABOUT
EIGHTY PER OF THE AND SO FRANCE
. MARTIN BUILDS PRIOR TO AND
WE'RE BUILT IN EIGHTY AND ARE
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES WE NEED TO
FIND OF MECHANISMS OTHER THAN
BUILDING CODES. ARTICLE THESE
EXISTING BUILDINGS FOR EXAMPLE
EXPANDING EXISTING
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAMS
REQUIRING ADEQUATE COOLING ON
POINT OF SALE HOMES. AND
REQUIRING COOLING EQUIPMENT
INSPECTION DURING OTHER HOME
INSPECTION. OR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES WHEN YOU'RE GOING
TO. FINALLY WE NEED TO PINE. AND
THEN. THESE PASSIVE ENACT
COOLING. THAT'S GONNA MENTION TO
DETERMINE WHAT WORKS BEST FOR
RESIDENTS AND TO DEVELOP BEST
PRACTICES. FOR INSPECTION
IMPLEMENTATION AND MONITORING
AND JUST A FEW EXAMPLES OF SOME
OF THE HIGH TECH MEASURES. HELLO
ON. SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
ATTENTION ON THERE IS A WEBSITE
THAT'S JUST COMING UP CALDERON
SORT OF RELIGION BE THAT HAS
LONG DISCIPLINE PERMISSION. AND
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ON THE SEC
CLIMATE CHANGE RESEARCH PROGRAM
FOR THEIR SUPPORT IN A RESEARCH
FUNDING HELLO WEST FRESNO FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER IN THE SHIP
CONSULTING AND USC. THANK YOU
JOHN. AT THANK YOU DR WAY AND-
WE DO APPRECIATE THE ENTIRE LABS
THE SERVICE TO NOT JUST THIS
COMMITTEE BUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND THE ACUITY WITH
WHICH YOU ANALYZE THE ISSUE
ACTUALLY GIVES US A LOT OF
INSIGHT AND TOOLS FOR MOVING
FORWARD- THAT'S THE DECK
INCLUDES THE INITIAL REMARKS
FROM OUR PANELISTS DID ANY
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THAT
THEY WANTED TO ASK I'M HAPPY TO
OPEN IT UP FOR A MOMENT HERE- IF
THERE ARE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS I
DID WANT TO ASK- ONE. ONE
QUESTION ABOUT THE I THINK FOR
OUR OUR LAWRENCE BERKELEY LABS
FOLKS- IN TERMS THE HEAT RANKING
SYSTEM THAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT AND- ANALYZING HE SORT OF
OUTSIDE OF THE HOME VERSES IN
THE HOME- HOW DO YOU ACTUALLY
FIGURE OUT WHAT. THE TEMPERATURE
IS INSIDE OF HOMES AND WHERE
THOSE DISPARITIES ARE
IDENTIFYING WHERE THEIR SWAMP
COOLERS OR WHERE THERE ARE NOT
TEN HOW TO MAP THAT IN A WAY YOU
MEAN WHEN YOU LOOK AT FOR
INSTANCE WHAT L. A. COUNTY
STATED THAT THEY ACHIEVED
THROUGH THE VULNERABILITY INDEX
. YOU HAVE THAT FOR YOU ALL WITH
ENOUGH FOR. TO SEARCH OF. TARGET
THE POPULATIONS THAT THEY WILL
NEED THAT ASSISTANCE TO THE
AREAS THAT NEED. MOST URGENTLY
SAY FOR THE URBAN HEAT ISLAND TO
BE BROKEN UP OR NEED A COOL ROOF
RETROFIT OR NEED NEW URBAN
GREENING OPPORTUNITIES I MEAN.
TAKE THERE'S LIMITLESS NEED HERE
BUT IN TERMS OF PRIORITIZATION
FRAMEWORK AND THE KIND OF DATA
WE NEED TO COST EFFECTIVELY
ATTACK THIS PROBLEM HOW DO YOU-
HOW DO YOU BUILD. ENOUGH
GRANULARITY TO THE DATA TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE WE'RE REACHING THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT MOST FIRST.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO START SURE
YEAH THAT'S SOME THE GREAT
WESTERN US SENATOR STERN AND I
THINK HER SEVERAL COMPONENTS OF
IT SO I'M NOT SURE THAT I COULD
DO IT JUSTICE MIDDLE TO START
AND THEN- RUNNING CAN RESPOND AS
WELL SO. I THINK ON THE FIRST
POINT YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT-
METRICS AND YOU MENTIONED HE DID
BACKS THERE'S A HUGE WARNING
SYSTEM WHICH IS BEING PILOTED BY
THE NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE
THERE'S A LOT OF. NOW SOUP OF.
METRICS OUT WHICH ARE LOOKING
OUT OUTDOOR COMFORT OR HELP
SEATING DECK OR OUTDOOR RISKS TO
WORKERS. FROM COST IN OUR
STUDENTS HOURS ON CRISTINA NEXT
. TO WHERE PALM LOW TEMPERATURE
WHICH TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
HUMIDITY SO SOME THERE'S
TEMPERATURE NUMBER ONE AND THEN
THERE'S- OTHER METRICS WHICH
INCLUDE HUMIDITY AND YOU CAN
ALSO LOOK AT YOUR SPEED. AND
ALSO LIKE A GRADIENT TEMPERATURE
WHICH IS STILL IN A RADIATION
FROM OTHER SERVICES. CAN ALSO
CARRY INSIDE OF THE HOME SO.
YOU'RE RIGHT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT WE TYPICALLY TEND TO
ENSURE OUTDOOR ALL. METRICS THAT
MAKES SENSE BECAUSE WE ACCESS
THOSE WE DON'T MEASURE ON.
INDOOR CONDITIONS SUCH AS
HUMIDITY AND AIRSPEED AND SO
FORTH BUT WE DO KNOW THAT MANY
FACTORS CAN IMPROVE YOUR COMFORT
SUCH AS HAVING FAMILY. WHICH CAN
IN TURN INCREASE AIRSPEED
REDUCING THE HUMIDITY WITHIN THE
HOME WHICH IS OPPOSITE OF WHAT
IT'S LONGER WITH US. BUT AIR
CONDITIONING ALSO. IT'S KIND OF
ON YOU KNOW IT IMPROVING THE
HUMIDITY IN YOUR HOME- SOMEONE
ARE WORK IN OUR MODELING WORK WE
DEFINITELY TRY TO. TAKE A LOT OF
THESE FACTORS INTO ACCOUNT AND
E TRY TO. LOOK AT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR- POTENTIAL
MEASURES. BY A SERIES OF. BUT
THE TECHNICAL COMFORT REALLY
COMFORT AND HEALTH METRICS
INCLUDING WELL I WON'T GO
THROUGH ALL THE NAMES BUT
THERE'S NOT THERE'S TO BE. SO
FOR. ME JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE NO
AND SO IT WENT HEARING FROM YOU
YOU. YOU'RE YOU'RE GETTING A
PRECISE ABOUT THE F. OF VERY
MITIGATE MEASURE. BUT THE- STILL
THAT SIR OF PRIORITIZATION. IN
GETTING SOLID ENOUGH. DATA TO
KNOW- IF LEAST YOU KNOW ROUGHLY
WHERE THE ISSUE IS RIGHT I MEAN
YOU YOU'VE IDENTIFIED- THE
THIRTY AMBIENT TEMPERATURE
ISSUES MAPPED OVER SAY INCOME OR
DIFFERENT VULNERABILITY INDEX.
AND THEN AT THAT POINT. YOU HAVE
SOME BEST PRACTICES TO DEPLOY
IN- AND THAT'S MAYBE WHERE
GOVERNMENT STARTS TO COME IN AND
START TO BUILD A LITTLE MORE.
GRANULARITY BUT MY ONLY OTHER
QUESTION THEN WAS FOR MISTER PAR
FREE IN TERMS OF. YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU CAN'T IDENTIFY EVERY SINGLE
HOUSE AND WHAT THEIR INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS ARE I KNOW. YOU'VE BEEN
ADVOCATING AND TEEING UP SORT OF
THOSE NO REGRETS MUCH LARGER
COMMUNITY WIDE SOLUTIONS THAT.
EVERYONE CAN BENEFIT FROM AND
THERE'S BEEN SOME CONTROVERSY OR
I GUEST- LIGHT SKEPTICISM MAYBE
IS THE WAY TO OPPOSE IT NOW
ABOUT. THINGS LIKE COOL ROOFS IN
COOL PAVEMENT. AND SOME SOME
SORT OFSUBTLE INDICATION MAYBE
IT'S FROM THE ASPHALT INDUSTRY
ABOUT SOME COLLATERAL EFFECTS
FROM GOING THIS WAY BUT I DID
WANT TO GIVE YOU. AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LAY TO REST ANY OF THAT
SKEPTICISM AND- JUST A LITTLE
GIVE A LITTLE MORE- WITH A
LITTLE MORE POINTEDNESS FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO UNDERSTAND- THOSE
ARE TO AMBIENT. ISSUES THAT YOU
CAN ACTUALLY TURN THE
TEMPERATURE DOWN IN A COMMUNITY
WITH- THAT YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE
TO TURN YOUR AC TEMPERATURE
DOWN. IT'S TURNED DOWN FOR YOU
BECAUSE THERE'S A TREE ON YOUR
STREET. AND IT'S NOT A GIANT.
ASPHALT PARKING LOT RIGHT IN
FRONT YOUR HOUSE BUT- BUT FOR
ALL THE COOLING SKEPTICS OUT
THERE JUST. WANTED. TO GIVE YOU
A QUICK CHANCE TO RESPOND- THANK
YOU SO- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE DON'T RECOGNIZE IS THAT
THESE COOLING MATERIALS CAN BE
MANUFACTURED. IN SUCH A WAY
WHERE YOU NEARLY HI CAMP DOWN.
ANY OF THE A GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THAT GOES INTO
PRODUCING SO THAT'S THAT IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT FACTS SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE THREE M. COMPANY
THAT RUNS ONLINE IN- CHINO-
CALIFORNIA- THAT THEY PROCESS
THEIR GRANULES THERE WITH A
SOLAR POWER. AS A WAY OF HAVING
A MORE- SORT OF HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO REDUCING- THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
THEIR PRODUCTS AND IN TALKING
WITH A NUMBER OF THE OTHER
VENDORS WHO PRODUCED THE COOL
PAVEMENT. REELS WHETHER IT'S THE
GAF COMPANY- OR OTHERS- THAT ARE
OUT THERE THE RECENT GREAT
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES. AND THEY
HAVE ASSURED ME THAT THEY CAN
PRODUCE ALL OF THEIR PRODUCTS A
USING RENEWABLE TECHNOLOGIES. TO
POWER THE PROCESSING AND
MANUFACTURING OF THOSE PRODUCTS-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT FOLKS
DON'T REALIZE IS THAT WHEN
YOU'RE WALKING ON THE SIDEWALK
YOU'RE ON CONCRETE AND CONCRETE
HAS THE SAME SOLAR REFLECTIVITY
. IS THE COOLEST THIS BURKE THE
SAME AND IT'S AROUND TWENTY
THREE THREE WHICH IS VERY
PROPITIOUS BECAUSE THAT'S THE
SAME AS A PRE INDUSTRIAL
SOCIETY- SOLAR REFLECTANCE IN
THE- THE MOON IF YOU DON'T LIKE
THE SUN'S REFLECTION WHEN YOU'RE
ON A SIDEWALK. WILL YOU WON'T
LIKE IT WHEN YOU'RE ON THE
STREET BUT I THINK MOST OF US
ARE QUITE ACCLIMATED TO THAT
DEGREE OF THE ALBEDO OF. SOLAR
REFLECTIVE YES. BY WALKING ON A
SIDEWALK SO THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME- COMPLAINTS ABOUT THAT-
THAT PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT
THE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS OF
THESE ARE PRODUCTS THAT SOME
PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
HUSTLER REFLECTIVE OF PROPERTIES
AND HOW IT MIGHT POTENTIALLY IN
THE MOMENT MADE PEOPLE. A LITTLE
BIT HARDER- BUT WE SIMPLY
HAVEN'T FOUND THOSE TO BE
INSURMOUNTABLE- OBSTACLES. TO A
WIDESPREAD. EXPERIMENT WITH THE
- WITH THESE COOLING. THERE IS
ONE MORE COOLING PRODUCT THAT'S
OUT THERE THAT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR A LOS ANGELES
AREA WHERE MOST OF THE COOLING
PRODUCTS USE A FOREIGN THOUGHT
TITANIUM. OF BASS- TITANIUM
OXIDE BASE TITANIUM IS
ESSENTIALLY BURKE LITTLE WHITE
PIECES OF SAND THAT YOU MIGHT
FIND ON THE BEACH IN YOUR
AGGREGATING THEM ALL TOGETHER
INTO ONE PLACE- AND THAT IS-
USING OF BARITE. FORMED EIGHT.
UNFORTUNATELY. TO DEATH. REFLECT
IN THE U. B. AND IT ACTS CAN. TO
A FORMING SMART AND SO OUR OUR
GOAL IS TO HAVE THE RIGHT KIND
OF TECHNOLOGY IN THE RIGHT PLACE
AND WE DON'T WANT TO FOR MORE
SMOG AND IN LOS ANGELES AND SO
THE ERROR I BASED MATERIALS THAT
ARE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE IN
REFLECTING SUNLIGHT. MAY NOT BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE SOUTH COAST
ON A QUEUE IN THE DISTRICT. SO
FORGET MY LONG ANSWER BUT- THERE
ARE THE RIGHT PRODUCTS FOR THE
RIGHT PLACE AT THE RIGHT TIME
AND I SHOULD ADD THAT ASSEMBLY
COMBO- AND- WITH THE- AND
CRESCENTS. NO THEY DO NOT NEED-
THE COOLING REMEDIES THAT WE'RE
SUGGESTING JUST THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE STATE WHERE THE
PUBLIC RESIDES THOSE ARE THE
PLACES THAT NEED THESE KINDS OF
CORNERS- THANKS FOR THE INSIGHT
AND- FOR LAYING OUT THAT
SPECTRUM THAT NOT ALL COOLING
TECHNOLOGIES ARE BUILT EQUAL
NECESSARILY BUT ALSO THAT.
THEY'RE THERE AND THEY'RE ON THE
SHELF AND WE JUST HAVE TO GO GET
THEM SO- LET'S TALK A LITTLE
MORE ON THIS UPCOMING PANEL WAS
THERE ANY QUESTIONS CENTER LIMÓN
YOU WANT TO WIN QUICKLY PLEASE
WELCOME. THANK YOU AND ONE QUICK
QUESTION SORRY AS I WAS
LISTENING TO THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE BEING MADE WE'VE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT- YOU KNOW THE HE IN
THE IMPACT FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
AND HEARD TESTIMONIALS AND JUST
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE SOUTH COAST
A. Q. M. D. WAS MENTIONED DO WE
KNOW ANYTHING- I THINK OF
COMMUNITIES LIKE WILMINGTON
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE THAT NOT
ONLY SUFFER SOME OF THESE HEAT
WAVES. BUT ALSO- HAVE BEEN KNOWN
TO HAVE JUST POLLUTANTS IN THE
AIR THAT ARE A SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER THAN OTHER COMMUNITIES DO
WE KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE
IMPACT- ON QUALITY COMBINED WITH
HEAT- BESIDES IT BEING. EXTRA
BAD- BUT ANYTHING THAT YOU COULD
PERHAPS SHARE AND THAT'S A
QUESTION TO ANY OF OUR PANELISTS
YEAH PERHAPS BECAUSE L. A.
COUNTY YOU JUST FINISH YOUR
VULNERABILITY INDEX MAYBE YOU
COULD TAKE A- EVEN A CLOSER
SNAPSHOT ON A COMMUNITY LIKE
WILMINGTON THAT SORT HAS THIS
COMPOUNDING EFFECTS THE CENTER
IS TALKING ABOUT. THEY'RE HAPPY
TO ADDRESS THAT THANK YOU. FOR
THE QUESTION. I'M SO WE ACTUALLY
FOUND. AIR QUALITY ACROSS OUR
REPORT LOOKED AT FIVE FINING
HAZARDS- EXTREME HEAT WAS JUST
ONE OF THEM. AIR QUALITY IS
WORSE THAN BY EVERY ON SIGN
HAZARD THAT. THE LA REGION FACES
. ACTUALLY NOT JUST EXTREME.
HEAT- SO HE MAKES OUR OUR OZONE
- ISSUES WORSE- THAT THAT IS A
NINE FOUR. BACKSPACE AND IT
OBVIOUS SEE PEOPLE THINK ABOUT
WILDFIRE BUT YES CERTAINLY. LIKE
AND ALSO THE NATURE OF. THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT RIGHT CAN READ
. THAT KEEPS SAY- MARKET
MOVEMENT. YOU INFRASTRUCTURE
LIKE ARE FREEWAYS. ARE PART OF
THE RE WHY IT'S PLACE LIKE
WILMINGTON ARE WARMER. BUT ALSO
OUR PER ARE DIRECTLY IN THE- I.
YOU KNOW THE CRITERIA THAT ARE.
A THEY'RE IMPACTING HEALTH THE
AIRPORT- PERSPECTIVE SO YES ERIC
IS. BY EXTREME OR AIR POLLUTION
IS BUSINESS. BY EXTREME HEAT. ON
EITHER ACTUALLY WITH ALL BUT-
THAT CRIMINALS IS THAT LIKE ANY
CASE. THANK YOU. BERMAN THANKS
FOR THAT IN WE CERTAIN KNOW THAT
- WHERE MISS STRATA WORKING- WAS
ANOTHER OF A LOT OF THE GOODS
MOVE IMAGE AND THE MARINO IS
YOUR OF AN ENTIRE FOR THAT OVER
THE SO- I DON'T KNOW IF SHE HAS
ANY- INSIGHT HELLO WHAT IT WAS
LIKE IN AT AMAZON WAREHOUSE BUT-
NOW THAT YOU'RE- A GRADUATE
STUDENT PERHAPS YOU CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT- BUT MISTER
STRADA ANY COMMENTS THERE JUST
AS SOMEBODY WAS LIVING THROUGH
WHAT- MYSTERIES PAULING WAS
TALKING ABOUT. OKAY WELL WE
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR TESTIMONY-
ANY FOLLOW UPS YOU'RE OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS- WE'LL WRAP THAT
PANEL UP FOR NOW- AND MOVE ON
TO- A PANEL REALLY FOCUSED ON
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE- NOT
JUST THE IMPACT SIDE BUT THE
ACTIONS- AND- THE ORDER I HAVE
HERE WE HAVE WE HAVE FIVE
PANELISTS FOR THREE MINUTES
EACH- AND I HAVE FIRST ON MY
LIST- KEVIN GALLEN. WHO IS THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
DIRECTOR- WITHIN L. A. COUNTY
AND PERHAPS CAN COMMENT ON SO
THE ACTION SIDE OF ADDRESSING
THESE HEAT WAVES- WHENEVER AND
WHEREVER THEY OCCUR- AND THEN
SORT OF. SENTIMENT THAT WHOSE
WITH GREEN LINING INSTITUTE WILL
TESTIFY AFTERWARDS ON- THE
BUILDING SIDE OF THINGS AND AS
WELL AS THEIR THEIR LARGER PUSH
AROUND- RESILIENCE ASSEMBLY
CASTEEL FROM WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WILL BE JOINING
US. AS WELL AS ARMY REVOL I WITH
A PEN AROUND RESILIENCE CENTERS
AND JOSE TAURUS WILL WRAP IT UP
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT- WE'RE
AT DECARBONISATION END. OF
EXTREME HEAT MITIGATION COULD
OVERLAP- BUT JUST TO KICK OFF-
DIRECTOR BEGAN WHEN YOU WANT TO
START. SALOON ON. WHEN YOUR
HANDS ARE ON THE TELLER LOOKING
FOR A OF MY- AND DISASTER EVERY
DAY IN THE MOST- DISASTER
EXPOSED COUNTY IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY- WHERE DOES HE PLAY INTO
YOUR- YOUR DAILY- RISK
MANAGEMENT. THANK YOU AG GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ADJOURNMENTS
STERN VICE CHAIRMAN RODRIGUEZ AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S COMING DOWN
IN A SERVICE THAT DIRECTOR OR
LAWSUIT COUNTY'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
THE EXTREME HEAT EMERGENCIES AND
HOW THE COUNTY. OF LOS ANGELES
IS MITIGATING AGAINST PREPARING
FOR RESPONDING TO AND RECOVERING
FROM THESE TYPES OF EVENTS. WE
DO THIS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH MANY
OF OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
COUNTY DEPARTMENT. NATIONAL
WEATHER SERVICE- LOCAL FIELD
OFFICE WHICH IS OUR LOS ANGELES
OFFICE- REGIONAL STATE AND
FEDERAL STATE VOTERS TO INCLUDE
SOME THAT YOU FOR TODAY AND THEN
OTHERS SUCH AS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA. BY VIRTUE OF OUR
RISK PORTFOLIO OUR SIZE AND
COMPLEXITY LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FACES MANY NUMEROUS CHALLENGES
WHEN. DISASTER STRIKES IN TWENTY
TWENTY. NATIONAL RISK INDEX TEAM
IDENTIFIED LOS ANGELES COUNTY AS
HAVING THE HIGHEST RISK INDEX OF
ALL COUNTIES IN THE NATION AND
THIS UNDERSCORES THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TO CONTINUE TO BUILD ITS
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT CAPACITY
CAPABILITIES WITH THE GOAL OF
HAVING AFFECTED RESILIENCE IN
THE FACE OF ALL OF OUR NATURAL
TECHNOLOGICAL. AND HUMAN CAUSED
DISASTERS INCLUDING EXTREME
URGENCY. IN RECENT YEARS LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HAS EXPERIENCED
NUMEROUS HEAT EVENTS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THERE WERE OVER TWENTY SEPARATE
SEAT EXTREME HEAT EVENTS THAT
AFFECTED L. A. COUNTY AND
RESULTED IN OUR LOCAL FIELD
OFFICE FROM THE NATIONAL WEATHER
SERVICE. ISSUING ADVISORIES AND
HE WARNS. THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
OF THESE TWENTY PLUS EVENTS
OCCURRED ON SEPTEMBER SIXTH.
TWENTY TWENTY. WHEN HISTORIC
RECORDS WERE SET INCLUDING A
COUNTY WIDE DAYTIME OR AT THE
COUNTY Y. DAYTIME HIGH OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY. ONE DEGREES IN
WOODLAND HILLS AND OUR OVERNIGHT
TEMPERATURES THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY REMAINING IN THE NINETIES
- OUR APPROACH TO- IT EXTREME
WEATHER OR EXTREME HEAT EVENTS.
IS THROUGH A UNITY OF EFFORT
WITH OUR LOCAL STATE FEDERAL AND
COMMUNITIES PARTNERS. WORDS ARE
CONCERNED TO DRESSING PLANNING
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY MITIGATION MEASURES.
THE COUNTY MAINTAINS A HAZARD
MITIGATION PLAN THAT'S TIED TO
OUR COUNTIES GENERAL PLAN SAFETY
ON IT. AND IT'S ALIGNED WITH OUR
COUNTIES CLIMATE VULNERABILITY
ASSESSMENT WHICH YOU'VE HEARD
FROM EARLIER. THESE PLANS INFORM
OUR WHOLE COMMUNITY APPROACH TO
THREATS RISKS AND HOW WE
OVERCOME THEM. IN ESSENCE THESE
PLANS PROVIDE THE PASSWORD
BUILDING COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
WHICH IS CRITICAL IN THIS. TYPE
OF AN EMERGENCY. THE COUNTY ALSO
MAINTAINS AN EXTREME TEMPERATURE
PLAN WHICH IS AN ANNEX TO OUR
COUNTY'S EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
PLAN. THESE PARTICULAR PLANS
PROVIDE STRATEGIES AND
FRAMEWORKS FOR HOW WE-
COORDINATE A COUNTY RESPONSE TO
EXTREME HEAT EMERGENCIES
INCLUDING WHAT EMERGENCY
PROTECTIVE MEASURES. MAY BE
NEEDED TO COMBAT THESE EFFECTS
IN THESE EMERGENCY SUCH AS
ESTABLISHING- AND OPERATING
VARIOUS DIFFERENT SITES LIKE
COOLING SITES. CONDUCTING OF
WATER ICE IN CRITICAL RESOURCE
COMMODITY DISTRIBUTION TO ARE
VULNERABLE AND AT RISK
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS REALLY THE
STRUCTURE SENATOR STERN THAT YOU
HAD ALLUDED TO AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE CONVERSATION WHEN. I
HEARD IN CAESAR KERR AND IN OUR
STATEWIDE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM CASING THE PLACE WHERE
THE COUNTY THROUGH ITS
OPERATIONAL AREA
RESPONSIBILITIES. BECOME STATE
COUNT BECOMES THE HUB AND SPOKE
IN. COORDINATING AND SUPPORTING
EFFORTS. WHEN EXTRA HEAT OVER DO
OCCUR CAL EMERGE C. STRUCTURES
ANY ACTS THAT INCLUDE GLUTEN
FORMING THE PUBLIC OF THE RISKS
POSED BY THE EMERGENCY AND
ACTIONS THAT CAN BE TAKEN TO
PROTECT INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES
FRIENDS AND COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONALLY THE COUNTY'S OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
COORDINATES AND SUPPORTS COUNTY
RIGHT EFFORTS TO PROTECT LIFE
PROPERTY AND ENVIRONMENT. AND
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE STRIVE FOR
THIS TO BE A WHOLE COMMUNITY
EFFORT. THE COUNTY EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT NATION REQUIRES THIS
AND ITS EVER PRESENT WITH OUR
STRONG ORGANIZATIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS. THAT TRAVERSE
LOCAL CITIES. THE NATIONAL
WEATHER SERVICE COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS CALLAWAY S. AND FEMA. A RECENT REPORTS AND STUDIES
FROM GOVERNMENT ACADEMIA AND NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
PRIVATE SECTORS CONTINUE SHOW
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE INDUCED
EMERGENCIES LIKE HEAT EXTREME.
HE DIVERGENCES ARE OCCURRING
WITH MORE FREQUENCY AND SEVERITY
SO OUR GOAL IN BUILDING
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES REQUIRES
VERY TARGETED EFFORTS
INVESTMENTS IN PUBLIC POLICY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT. FOR EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT I RECOMMEND US
EXPLORING A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES ONE REVISING OUR
GRANT METHODOLOGIES REQUIREMENTS
AND PERFORMANCE PERIOD FOR
CERTAIN GRANTS THAT EFFECT
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT LIKE THE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT PERFORMANCE
GRANT. AND BUILDING RESILIENT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN COMMUNITIES
GRANTS THAT CONSIDER THE
NATIONAL RISK INDEX AND ALSO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THE MORE
SIGNIFICANT TIME THAT'S IT
THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPLEMENTING THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS TO REDUCE THE THREATS
TO EXTREME HEAT EMERGENCIES. I
ALSO THINK WE SHOULD EXPLORE
INCREASING FUNDING FOR EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT PERFORMANCE GRANT AND
THEN HOW THOSE GRANTS FLOW
THROUGH FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO THE STATE AND INTO
LOCAL MUICIPAL GOVERNMENTS. AND
BUILDING ON OUR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE GRANTS SO THAT THESE
ARE COMMENSURATE WITH THE
GROWING FREQUENCY AND SEVERITY
OF CLIMATE CHANGE INDUCED
EMERGENCIES. AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. BEFORE YOU
COMMITTEE TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DIRECTOR MCALLEN- NEXT UP WE
HAVE SORT OF A NON. OF THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE INSTITUTE- WHO
ACTUALLY SERVED ON THE TASK
FORCE TO DEVISE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER ON THE NEED FOR
EXTREME HEAT RANKING PROPOSAL
THAT'S NOW RESULTED IN SOME
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THAT I'M A
CO AUTHOR WITH A NUMBER MY
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES AND I THINK
IF YOU. SENATORS TO- MISSED
MANAT- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US TODAY AND FOR YOUR
ADDRESS HERE ON SO MANY FRONTS
ON BEHALF THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
STERN AND GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY. MY
NAME IS ON A MONDAY AND THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF KIND
EQUITY AT THE CLEANING IN THE
QUEUE. AND REMAINING WORKS
TOWARD A FUTURE WHERE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO BUILD
TWELVE LET AND HEALTHY PLACES
FILLED WITH ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY. AND ARE READY TO
MEET THE CHALLENGES POSED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE. ATTENDERS ARE
MENTIONED WE WERE A MEMBER OF
THE PLANET INSURANCE WORKING
GROUP CONVENED BY INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA. THAT
WORK ON A REPORT PUBLISHED LAST
FALL TITLED PROTECTING
COMMUNITIES CONSERVING NATURE
AND BUILDING RESILIENCE B. ONE
OF THE KEY FINDINGS IN THAT
REPORT. THAT WE NEED TO INCREASE
AWARENESS OF THE DANGERS THE MAT
BUT EXTREME HEAT POSES.
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND ONE OF
OUR REPORT RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
I WANTED TO SPEAK BRIEFLY ABOUT
TODAY. IT'S RAIN HEAT WAVE
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DO FOR
HURRICANE. THAT WE CAN GET
INFORMATION ABOUT EXTREME HEAT
TRACK COMMUNITIES. TO PROMOTE
SAFETY AND PREVENT THAT. THIS
REPORT EXPO TO HEAT IF ONE OF
THEM INTO THE THINGS THAT L<c.cyan>G</c>
COMMUNITY OF COLOR VARIANTS.
FORMALLY READ MY NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE KHADDAM LOWER INCOME OF
COLOR LAND AND TO HAVE YOUR
TREAT PARK. I CAN PROVIDE SHADE
AND COOLING LACK ACCESS TO AIR
CONDITIONING AND ARE OFTEN
LOCATED NEXT TO A LOT OF HEAT
TRAPPING CONCRETE AND ASPHALT
SURFACES THAT CAN RADIATE HEAT.
IN A STUDY OF OVER HUNDRED URBAN
AREAS IN THE U. S. FORMERLY
REDLINED NEIGHBORHOODS AND
NEARLY EVERY CITY WERE HOTTER
THAN THE NON REDLINED
NEIGHBORHOODS. ESPECIALLY FOR
BLACK COMMUNITY DONE BY NEARLY
THIRTEEN DEGREES. AND ALL OF
THIS ADDS UP TO EXTREMELY HIGHER
TEMPERATURES IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
INCREASED HEALTH AND SAFETY RISK
. THE RECOGNIZING THE SEVERE
THREAT THAT EXTREME HEAT HOLDEN
ESPECIALLY OUR FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES TREATING IT AS AN
EMERGENCY AS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO BETTER PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITY. UNDER THE PLAN THE
INSURANCE WORKING GROUP WHATEVER
RECOMMENDATION IS TO CREATE A
DATA CENTER RANKED HEATWAVE. AND
WE HAVE MODELS WE CAN LOOK TO
SUCH AS CALIFORNIA'S RED FLAG
WARNING FOR WILDFIRE CONDITIONS
AND NO WAS RANKING SYSTEM FOR
TROPICAL STORMS AND HURRICANES.
REMINDING GROWING UP IN NEW.
DURING SEASON HAVING INFORMATION
ABOUT WEATHER STORM COULD BE A
TROPICAL STORM OR CATEGORY ONE.
HURRICANE WITH EXTREMELY HELPFUL
THAT MY FAMILY COULD MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER WE
NEEDED TO BOARD UP WINDOWS AND
YOU STAND BACK CHECKING ON
NEIGHBORS. AND IT HELPED AT THE
SITE IF YOU COULD STAY HOME WITH
SAFE ENOUGH OR IF YOU NEED TO
EVACUATE. HE PLAYED RANKING
SYSTEM WE SIMILARLY RECOMMENDING
CATEGORIES AND INFORMATION ABOUT
THE- LOCATION IT'S LEVEL OF
SEVERITY AND DURATION TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THE PUBLIC TO TRACK.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND INCLUDING
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO TAKE BASED ON THE
INTENSITY OF THE HEATERS AND-
AND LASTLY ENSURING EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO THIS COMMUNICATION
WILL NEED TO BE A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF THE SYSTEM. ARTICLE
WRITING WITH THE TESTING IN
AWARENESS ABOUT THE HEALTH RISKS
OF EXTREME HEAT AND CAN HELP
ENABLE POLICYMAKERS TO DEVELOP
RISK REDUCTION STRATEGIES. AND
HELP COMMUNITIES BETTER PREPARE
FOR EXTREME WEATHER. IN ADDITION
OF THIS RANKING SYSTEM FOR HEAT
WAVE WE ALSO NEED A
SIMULTANEOUSLY INVESTING POLICY
INTERVENTIONS THAT CAN DIRECTLY
MEDICAID HARM. EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO COOLING AND RESILIENCE
CENTERS WITH MY COLLEAGUES WILL
BE COME OUT SHORTLY. SO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
THE ATTENDANCE. EQUALITY
JACKIE'S THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH YOU SO MUCH RESTAURANT- I
THINK NEXT WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING
ON TO ARMY REBEL WITH A PEN THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK. I'M SORRY DID I MISS
THAT YES I'M SORRY MISS CASTEEL-
DO WE HAVE SENT A KESTEVEN ALONG
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. POLITIES THANK YOU
WELCOME. HI GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBER CYNTHIA CASTEEL POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY SO THRILLED TO
BE ANCHORED ON THIS PANEL FOR
OVER FIVE DECADES WESTERN CENTER
HAS ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
POVERTY THROUGH THE LENS OF
ECONOMIC AND RACIAL JUSTICE
USING OUR THREE PRIMARY AREAS OF
EXPERTISE WHICH IS ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE PUBLIC BENEFITS AND
HOUSING WE'RE PROUD TO BE A PART
OF A GROWING COALITION COLLETTE
BY THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION REGIONAL
ASTHMA MANAGEMENT. AND
PREVENTION INTERCITY LAWCENTER
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL MADE UP OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND TEN ADVOCATES WHO ARE
CALLING ON THE STATE TO SET
STANDARDS FOR INDOOR AIR
TEMPERATURE TO ADDRESS EXTREME
HEAT I HOUSING PLACES OF
GATHERING IN REFUGE SUCH AS
WORKPLACES AND THE HOME SHOW
HIGH OCCURRENCES OF HEAT RELATED
ILLNESS AND DEATH. CALIFORNIA'S
HABITABILITY LAWS WHICH ADDRESS
BASIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS FOR RENTAL HOUSING
CURRENTLY. FAILED TO ACCOUNT FOR
EXTREME HEAT. OUR ORGAN. WORK
ALONGSIDE RESIDENTS BETTER
ACUTELY AND DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY
GROWING CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
TRAGIC AND UNACCEPTABLE RISE OF
HEAT RELATED DEATHS IN THE LAST
DECADE. RECENT MEDIA STORIES IT
HIGHLIGHTED THE INCREASE IN
THESE ISSUES AND THE STATE'S
BASS UNDER COUNTING OF DEATHS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO EXTREME HEAT.
BUT THE TRUTH TOLD A CRISIS IS
LIKELY SIX TIMES HIGHER THAN
REPORTED AND THIS NUMBER DOES
NOT INCLUDE IMPACTS TO FAMILIES
RELATED ILLNESS WHICH DID NOT
OPEN. TO SOMEONE'S DEATH. THE
STORY IS ALSO CLEAR THAT LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS PARTICULARLY
IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
INCREASINGLY VULNERABLE TO THE
IMPACTS REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY LIVE IN RURAL OR URBAN
AREAS AND IN A RANGE OF HOUSING
HI. AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CHILDREN THE ELDERLY PEOPLE WITH
PRE EXISTING HEALTH CONDITIONS
FARMWORKERS THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES AND JUST LARGELY
THE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THAT ARE AT RISK. AND LIKE
MANY ISSUES THIS FALLS ON CLEAR
INCOME LINES FOR PEOPLE WITHOUT
ACCESS WITH THE HOME AIR
CONDITIONING OR SHADE HE CAN BE
DANGEROUS AND ULTIMATELY DEADLY.
AND IN ADDITION TO HEAT
EXHAUSTION AND HEATSTROKE
EXTREME HE CAN WORSEN
CARDIOVASCULAR AND RESPIRATORY
PROBLEMS INCREASING THE RISK OF
STROKES HEART ATTACKS IN ASTHMA
ATTACKS NOT TO MENTION THE
EFFECTS IT CAN HAVE ON
MEDICATION AND MEDICAL EQUIPMENT
STORAGE. THE MOST ALARMING AND I
THINK THAT LINE HERE IS THAT
THESE TYPES THAT'S OUR 100%
PREVENTABLE. CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY IMPOSES UNIFORM
OBLIGATIONS AND ALL LANDLORDS TO
MAINTAIN HABITABLE HOUSING SUCH
AS FUNCTIONING WATER ELECTRICAL
AND HEATING SYSTEM BUT DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANY STANDARD TO BE MET
AND CONNECTION WITH EXTREME
HEAT. THE RESULT IS THAT MUCH OF
OUR HOUSING STOCK IS MISSING
BASIC INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN MADE- BACK TO REALLY BLOCK
MUCH OF THE IMPACTS OF EXTREME
HEAT SUCH AS PROPERLY INSULATING
HOMES PROVIDING SHADE. HE FOUND. A VOICE HIGH AND ARE KIND.
DESPITE HERE- OVER YEAR I TEMP.
AND MORE FOR AND SEVERE HE- THE
DOES NOT CURRENTLY WORK. LINE TO
INSURE THAT TEIR UNITS CAN
MAINTAIN A MAXIMUM TEMPERATURE
AND THAT SUPPORTS BASIC. BASIC
HEALTH AND WELL BEING. OUR
CLIENTS ARE LEFT DEFENSELESS
FROM EXCRUCIATING HEAT BASED ON
THE UNEQUAL COOLING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE STATE THAT
FAVORS INDIVIDUALS WITH MONEY
PRIVILEGE BETTER HOUSING
OPPORTUNITY AND GREEN SPACE. AND
CLEARLY EVERY PERSON IN THE
STATE DESERVES TO LIVE IN A HOME
THAT PROTECTS THEM FROM
TEMPERATURE EXTREMES WHETHER
IT'S COLD OR HOT. THE CLEAREST
AND MOST COMMON SENSE SOLUTION
TO PREVENT THE NEEDLESS HE
RELATED THAT. THAT WE'RE SEEING
IS ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIANS
HAVE AN ACCESS TO A SAFE AND HOW
HOME WHERE THEY CAN FIND REFUGE
FROM EXTREME HEAT AND ITS
CONSEQUENT EFFECTS. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE WITH CHANGES TO
REGULATIONS THAT MATCH OUR
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND EQUITABLE MANNER. AND
OF COURSE FUNDING INVESTMENT OF
RESOURCES. SO AGAIN I REALLY
APPRECIATE BEING PUT ON THIS
PANEL THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU MISS CASTILLO A VERY
INSIGHTFUL COMMENTS AND- FOR.
YOUR DRILLING DOWN ON THIS. THE
LANDLORD TENANT ISSUE IN SOME OF
THOSE POWER DISPARITIES THAT END
UP RESULTING IN- IN TRAGEDIES WE
DO APPRECIATE THE- THE
TESTIMONY- I MEAN RECALL- EIGHT.
FREQUENT TESTIFY TO THIS
COMMITTEE. AND IT AND AGREED
ARCHITECT OF OUR WORK LAST YEAR
AND- JUST A TREMENDOUS ADVOCATE
WE DO APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
BEHALF APE AND WELCOME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY- I'M GRATEFUL TO BE HERE
REPRESENTING A PAN ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK. WE'RE
GRASSROOTS ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
WORK THAT WORKS WITH ASIAN
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES IN THE BAY AREA.
MANY OF WHOM ARE MONOLINGUAL AN
ELDERLY- AND WE ORGANIZE ON A
MULTITUDE OF CLIMATE JUSTICE
ISSUES. ARE WERE ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA BARBARA
JUSTICE ALLIANCE SOLIDARITY WITH
FARMWORKERS RURAL COMMUNITIES
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AND WORKING
CLASS COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
ACROSS THE STATE. CALIFORNIA IS
BEING PUSHED TO EXTREMES WE HEAR
SCIENTISTS SAY THAT THERE ISN'T
REALLY A NORMAL ANYMORE AND THAT
WHEN YOU ADD THESE CRISES
TOGETHER THE IMPACT IS
CUMULATIVE. FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN PLAGUED WITH THE BURDEN OF
APOSTLE FUEL POLLUTING
INDUSTRIES FOR GENERATIONS
THERE'S REALLY NOTHING YOU ABOUT
CUMULATIVE HEALTH CURTAINS. THIS
IS THE CASE IN RICHMOND WHERE WE
ORGANIZE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
LIVING ON THE FENCE LINE OF THE
CHEVRON REFINERY. FOR US THE
CLIMATE CLIMATE CRISIS IS
PERVASIVE. MEANING IT IS FELT
DAILY NOT JUST DURING TIMES OF
DISASTER. THIS MEANS CHRONIC AIR
POLLUTION OIL SPILLS GLARING
EXCLUSIONS AS WELL AS HE WADES
BLACKOUTS PARISHIONERS. AND
WILDFIRE'S SMOKE. ADDITIONAL
MODELS OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
HOWEVER ARE PROVING DEEPLY
INADEQUATE. THE COORDINATED
THROUGH MILITARIZED ENTITIES
LIKE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT THEY
WILL PUT MY UPON PROTOCOLS LIKE
EVACUATING TO FAR AWAY SITE LIKE
FAIRGROUNDS. THEY SHARE ALERTS
IN ONE TO TWO LANGUAGES THEY
PROVIDE AN EMPTY SPACE WITHOUT
TAILORED SERVICES AND
PROGRAMMING. THESE TYPES OF
POLICIES ARE COLLECTIVELY
COLLECTIVELY SHUTTING OUT MANY
MANY PEOPLE FROM THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED. YOUR HISTORIC
DISINVESTMENT HOWEVER OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE HAD TO BE
INCREDIBLY RESILIENT OR
ORGANIZING FOR CHANGE IN
INNOVATING LOCAL MODELS OF CAR
FOR CRISIS RESPONSE. WHEN
DISASTERS STRIKE WE SEXY TIME
AND TIME AGAIN COMMUNITIES COME
TOGETHER PROTECTING EACH OTHER
AND REBUILDING TOGETHER THROUGH
MUTUAL AID WORKS TO SHARE
RESOURCES SCHOOLS PROVIDING FOOD
TO FAMILIES WHERE COMMUNITY
CENTERS PROVIDING ELECTRICITY
ACCESS BUT WE NEED PROPER
INVESTMENT AND RESOURCES. EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION SUPPORT DISASTER
REPORT PUBLISHED THIS NEED AND
CALLS FOR TARGETED INVESTMENTS
TO BOLSTER THE SOCIAL FABRIC AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THAT MEANS INVESTING IN THE
SERVICES AND FACILITIES THAT
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE AND
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE QUICK TO
RESPOND. ONE EXAMPLE OUR
RESILIENCE HUBS THE
TRANSFORMATION OF TRUSTED
BUILDINGS LIKE LIBRARIES YOUTH
AND SENIOR CENTER FOR HEALTH
CLINICS INTO FACILITIES THAT
OFFER SPACE TO GATHER AND ACCESS
SERVICES. NOT ONLY DURING TIMES
OF STOCK IN DISASTERS LIKE KEEP
WEIGHTS BUT ARE THERE ON A DAILY
BASIS. THEY MADE POSSIBLE THE
SIMULTANEOUS INVESTMENT IN
SOLUTIONS LIKE IMPROVING
INSULATION FOR COOLING AND
HEATING CLEAN ENERGY
INSTALLATION FOR BACKUP POWER
DURING GRID OUTAGES OR AIR
FILTRATION SYSTEMS TO COMBAT
LAMPARD SMOKE. ONE EXAMPLE IS
THE RISE NEED CENTER WHICH A
PLAN IS COLLABORATING WITH
BECOME A YOUTH LED RESILIENCE
CENTER WHICH ONCE COMPLETE WILL
PROVIDE A SAFE SPACE FOR CLIMATE
RESPOND. AS WELL AS EXPANDED
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND YOUTH
SERVICES AND IMPORTANTLY THE
DENTURES GO FAR BEYOND NARROWLY
DEFINED COOLING CENTERS CAN
PROVIDE BY OFFERING A SUITE OF
INTEGRATED MEASURES BEYOND
CLIMATE RELIEF SUCH AS FOOD
DISTRIBUTION WATER EMERGENCY
SUPPLY. INTERNET ACCESS AND
CHILD CARE ON IN ENTERTAINMENT-
AND PROGRAMMING JUST TO NAME A
FEW ALL LOCATED WITHIN COMMUNITY
BUILDINGS PEOPLE TRUST AND
ALREADY GATHERING SO WITH THAT I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT. THAT CREATED
IN AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
QUESTION. THANK YOU MEASURE OUT
DO IT- THANK LAST ON OUR PANEL
WE HAVE- MR TAURUS JOSE TAURUS
FROM THE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION COALITION.
WELCOME MR TAURUS NEITHER BE
SCREENED. YOU'RE WITH US HELLO
SB NINETY THREE YES SIR NORI. SO
MUCH FOR THE INVITATION GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERMAN STERN
MASTERMAN RODRIGUEZ MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS JOSE TARZAN ON THE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR RIAN
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
COALITION. BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION COALITION UNITED
DIVERSE SET OF STAKEHOLDERS IN
TWO DEPARTMENTS BUILT
ENVIRONMENT AND. LEVERAGE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION- AS A
VEHICLE FOR CREATING FOR ONE
HEALTHY HOMES COMMUNITIES TRUMP
CALIFORNIANS TO ALL ELECTRIC
BUILDINGS. SO NO IN THE CONTEXT
OF EXTREME HEAT RIGHT REALLY
THINKING ABOUT ELECTRIFICATION
RYAN SEGAL IN A WORKSTATION
OPENING A PATHWAY TO HEALTHY
AFFORDABLE AND RESILIENT AND
BUILDINGS OVERALL IT WAS A MEAN
INCREASE TO HELP THE WHIMS ONLY
CALL. NINE ELECTRIFICATION TAKE
ON THE CLIMATE CRISIS WHICH IS
CONFIDENCE WE NEED ANOTHER
EXTREME WEATHER- YOU KNOW EVENTS
LIKE WILDFIRES BUT ALSO LUMINATE
THE KNOX POLLUTION OUR HOMES AND
WORKPLACES- AS WE KNOW THIS IS
PARTIALLY IMPACTED MUSIC
COLORING CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY
ARE MORE EXPOSED TO CONSTITUTION
AND WHEN IT COMES TO BUILDINGS
AND HOMES HOME SPECIFICALLY
RIGHT VIROLOGISTS COMMUNITIES
MORE LIKELY TO LITTLE OLDER
SMALLER LESS ANIMATED MORE CRIME
MOMENTS THEREFORE THE WAY WE'RE
LOOKING AT BUILDING ELECTION
COMMISSION AS WE WERE HOPING WE
CAN HELP LOWER INCOME AND
DISPENSED YUNIS. IN ALL
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTHIER
AFFORDABLE AND SAFE HOMES ALONG
WITH CREATING NEW JOBS AND
CHRYSOCOLLA OVER CALIFORNIANS
ALSO LEARN THE BEST FACILITIES
LIKE SCHOOLS AND RESILIENCE
CENTERS SO NOW I CAN TAKE A DEEP
DIVE INTO THE STREAM HE WANTED
TO LIVE AS WE THINK ABOUT IT-
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
POVERTY IS A STRONG INDICATOR-
STRONGER INDICATOR OF WHETHER
FOLKS HAVE ACCESS OR
CONDITIONING THANKS I AM IT. SO
NOT ONLY DO WE WANNA CERTAINLY
FIND HOMES MAKING IN THE LECTURE
FREDDIE IN ORDER TO COMBAT AND
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE SHOULD
PROVIDE ALL THE BENEFITS THAT
WERE HOPING TO GET TO A SAFETY
TO SAY OR HOW THE HOME THAT WE
WANT TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE.
RELIEF TO THOSE MOST IN NEED. SO
WE TALK ABOUT THE AMERICAN. FROM
BUILDING LIKE. PERSPECTIVE WORKS
ABOUT STRAIGHT. HE COMES. THE
LAST OUR DEGREE. I TECHNOLOGY
COOLEY AND HE HOMES AND THIS
IMAGE SHOWS ONE. AND CAN BE. AT
WORK- WELL VIRGIN I THINK THIS
MAY- ANY- ALSO BE THE- A SALES
JUST IN ALSO PROVIDE MUCH MORE
CARE WILL NEED TO FOLLOW. YOU
CAN LOOK IT'S BEEN OR HOW BUCKS. THE BOOKS. ON AND IN
STABILISATION PLAN FOR AND THE
AIR AND WITH THAT HE PUMP- SO WE
DISEASES TO AND THE COMMISSION
BUT THIS OUR AYE FOR RECENT AS
WE THINK WE NEED A MAN STOCKS OF
PEACE PROSPECTS NOT ON COMBAT
TIME AND CHANGE BUT ALSO TO TAKE
ON EXTREME- SO FOLKS FIND THE
GAS FOR QUINCY MILLION YEAH. AT
TWENTY THIRTY- BUT TO SEE SECRET
. IT JUST PROPOSAL SIX. HE LIKE
TO THIRTY METERS FINAL BUT I
DON'T WE ARE OF BILLS FROM FROM
OUR STATE. WILL ALSO BE PROVIDED
. LICENSE. SO FIRST OFF ONE IS
UP AND ASK SORRY. ANOTHER REASON
SUPPOSE TO CLOSE ONE MILLION-
THE FOR ADULTS DECARBONIZATION
WE THANK OFFERS A CRITICAL. TO
RETROFIT HOMES IMMEDIATE
COMMUNITIES WHILE ALSO TACKLING
OUR CLIMATE TARGETS- AND YOU
KNOW WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A
NEED FOR INVESTING BOTH IN HOMES
IN PUBLIC FACILITIES. NOT ONLY
ARE WHERE ALL. EIGHT RESILIENCE
CENTERS AND PLACES LIKE SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITIES START WHILE ALSO
TRANSITION OUR- FAMILY AND IS
ALIENATING WHILE ENSURING WE
HAVE BEEN GETTING JOBS AND
CREATED WORKFORCE REALLY TRYING
TO CONNECT RIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE
TO SOME OF THE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
FRIENDS AND OTHERS MENTION- AND
WE THINK THAT DETERMINATION IS
ONE WAY TO TAKE. ME. A LOT OF
THE OTHER SHOULD BE ABLE. THANK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
RESTORES- WE WILL- TURN TO
QUESTIONS NOW- NOTHING FOR MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE I
HAVE A COUPLE OF FOLLOW UPS- I
GUESS I'LL START. I'LL START
LAST TO FIRST- JUST TO FOLLOW UP
YOU WITH YOU BRIEFLY MR TORE AS-
IN TERMS OF HOW. PEOPLE HEAR THE
WORD HEAT PUMP AND THEY THINK
IT'S JUST- PUMPING HEAT INTO THE
HOUSE BUT- THESE ARE TWO WAY
MACHINES IN AND HOW DO THEY-
WHAT WHAT WHAT ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT COST WISE OF. OF GETTING
AN INSTALLATION DONE- COMPARED
TO THE SORT OF UP FRONT COSTS OF
THE ALTERNATIVE. YEAH HE SAID
CERTAIN THE PORTION YES- BOX
RIGHT THE NAME DOES THIS MAKE IT
SEEM LIKE IT WOULD ONLY BE FOR
HEATING BUT HE TALKS TO BILLS
CLEANS. AND HITTING RIGHT AND
THAT'S BECAUSE HE'S NOT SCHOOL
HE FROM. THE COLD OUTDOOR AIR
TRANSFERRED INDOORS IN WARMER
MONTHS AND THEY CAN ALSO PULL HE
TERM OUT FROM INDOOR AIR TO
CLEAR HOME RIGHT SO THAT'S
THAT'S HOW THEY FUNCTION. IN
TERMS OF CAGR- YOU KNOW THEY'RE
TERRIBLE AND SOMETIMES EVEN MORE
AFFORDABLE YOU THINK OF
PURCHASING A WHOLE H. FAX SYSTEM
RIGHT WE'VE SEEN. SAVINGS OF UP
TO THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS WHEN
YOU'RE REPLACING BOTH FURNACE.
AND AN AIR CONDITIONING UNIT AND
YOU KNOW WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE
NEED TO BUILD A MARKET FOR IT
RIGHT ENHANCE WHY WE APPRECIATE
KIND OF THE INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED. BECAUSE WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT- IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT FOLKS HAVE MORE
ACCESS TO IT THAT YOU CAN
TECHNOLOGY. ALTHOUGH READILY
AVAILABLE BECOMES MORE
MAINSTREAM AND STUFF THANKS- AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT FOLKS CAN
RELY ON- YOU KNOW FOR ME- AND
DEALING WITH EXTREME EIGHT. AND
I MEAN TO IT AFTER ABOUT HEAT
PUMPS JUST A QUICK ANECDOTE FROM
FAMILY MEMBER AND- GOES IF I IF
I MAY SENATOR- YEAH. AND IT GOES
BACK TO CENTER THE MOST
QUESTIONS EARLIER- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN MARINO VALLEY- ENOUGH
BOOKS ABOUT MORALITY. AND YOU
KNOW THEY WERE DEALING WITH YOU
KNOW WHILE YOU. LONG IT DIDN'T
PULL DOWN HOME SO THAT WAS
ALREADY A CHALLENGE AND
WILDFIRES ARE HAPPENING HERE IN
THAT THIRD AS WELL SO YOU REALLY
RARELY SEEN WHEN I WAS AT THE
RESIDENTS FAMILY MEMBER THE
CHALLENGER. DO YOU TURN ON THE
AIR CONDITIONING THAT DOESN'T
HAVE INFILTRATION- LIKE HE
COMPLAINED- OR DO YOU OR DO YOU
AND IT IS AS AND I CAN BE TURNED
HERE THE MORNING AT THE ASHES
ARE COMING IN. THE ASHES ARE
COMING IN- OR DO YOU DEAL WITH A
105 DEGREES HEAT AND NOT TURN IT
ON I THINK UNFORTUNATELY THE
SITUATION THAT MANY CALIFORNIANS
ARE DEALING WITH. AND EVEN IN
SOME AREAS WHERE YOU DON'T
MEANWHILE SPOKE TO BE SUFFERING.
REALLY BAD OUT THERE FOLLOWING
SIMPLY THINK THAT THINKING ABOUT. THIS LIST SICKENING GIVES THAT
OPPORTUNITY. WELL THAT'S THAT'S
ONE CONCLUDES I WOULD SAY I
WOULD FROM THIS. INTO WE'LL BE
TALKING TO. SUBS PAN AND GIVING
THEM SOME OF OUR FEEDBACK BASED
ON THIS TESTIMONY BUT- YOU KNOW
WE WE'VEHEARD TESTIMONY ABOUT-
THE EXTREME HEAT. FUNDING
EFFORTS AND STRATEGIES GOING ON
THERE'S- THERE'S BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION EFFORTS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S UNDERTAKING.
THERE'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INVESTMENTS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
UNDERTAKING THERE'S ENERGY
EFFICIENCY INVESTMENTS WERE
UNDERTAKING. AND LOOKING FOR
THOSE ALIGNMENTS WHERE DOES THE
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
INVESTMENTS. AND ARE INFILL
HOUSING INVESTMENTS WHERE CAN
THEY LEVERAGE ALSO COOLING
OPPORTUNITIES- WHERE CAN WE FIND
THE INTERFACE BETWEEN SAY. A
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES IN INVESTING IN
URBAN GREENING- IN COOL ROOFS IN
OPEN SPACE ALONG SIDE AN UP LIFT
EFFORT WITHIN THE HOME AROUND-
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION IT
ALSO. IMPROVES COOLING LOOKING
FOR THOSE SYNERGIES I THINK WILL
BE CRITICAL TO MAKING- OUR
INVESTMENT STRATEGY COST
EFFECTIVE FIRST OF ALL BUT ALSO.
TO NOT EXPECT GOVERNMENT TO HAVE
THAT MANY INTERVENTION POINTS IT
IS VERY DIFFICULT TO REACH
PEOPLE WHEN THEY ARE NOT.
FAMILIAR WITH THE SYSTEM AND
THAT'S WHERE. ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
MISS KRISTY OZER. MISMA NOT SIR
MISS REBELS ARE VERY IMPORTANT-
IN CONNECTING US TO COMMUNITY.
BUT YOU KNOW SINCE WE HAVE
MISTER MACALLAN HERE WHO'S AT
THE HELM- DO WHEN BAD THINGS
HAPPEN I JUST. I AM NOT SURE
WHAT WHAT NUMBERS YOU'VE GOT- ON
YOU. IF YOU'RE ARE STILL
AVAILABLE BUT- I DID WANT TO
DRILL DOWN AND JUST GET A SENSE
OF HOW MANY- WHAT THE RESOURCE
MIX LOOKS LIKE IN A IN A COUNTY
THE SIZE OF LA- DO YOU HAVE A
SENSE OF HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE AT
RISK DURING ANY GIVEN HE'D HAVE
BEEN. AND HOW MANY CENTERS FOR
INSTANCE THAT WE HAVE FOR THOSE
FOLKS I MEAN WHAT WHAT IS THE
SORT OF- RISK TO MITIGATION TOOL. PROPORTION LOOK LIKE RIGHT NOW
. YEAH I THINK SAID SENATOR
STERN SO. A LOT OF OUR DATA IS
KIND OF ANECDOTAL FROM PREVIOUS
EXPERIENCES THE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION AT THE BEGINNING YOU
KNOW WE BASED OUR MITIGATION
MEASURES OR OUR OUR EMERGENCY
PROTECTIVE MEASURES I SHOULD
SAY- ON ON THE NATIONAL WEATHER
SERVICE IS FORECAST FOR SPECIFIC
AREAS SO L. A. COUNTY SO
GEOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE YOU CAN
HAVE AN EXTREME HEAT EMERGENCY
OCCURRING IN ONE PART OF THE
COUNTY AND MODERATE TO NORMAL
CONDITIONS IN ANOTHER PART OF
THE COUNTY. SO OUR RESPONSE IS
VERY MUCH BASED ON THE REAL
WORLD FORECAST THAT WE'RE
GETTING AND THEN THE DEPLOYMENT
OF RESOURCES TO THOSE AFFECTED
AREAS. WITHIN THAT WE WORK WITH
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
ALONG WITH OUR CITIES TO
IDENTIFY YOU KNOW AREAS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE MOST VULNERABLE WE
IMPACTED SO BY THAT I MEAN. YOU
KNOW CERTAIN COMMUNITIES CAN
TAKE HIGHER LEVELS OF HEAT THEN
OTHER COMMUNITY STOPS OF URGENCY
MANAGEMENT- ISN'T THE
ORGANIZATION THAT MAKES THAT
DETERMINATION THAT'S USUALLY
DONE. IN COLLABORATION BETWEEN
THE NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE IS
FORECASTING OR COUNTIES
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SPECIFICALLY ARE COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICER. AND WE I NEED SHE
COORDINATION MEETINGS AS THIS
PROCESS GOES ON TO IDENTIFY
AREAS THAT ARE GOING TO BE MOST
IMPACTED AND THAT'S WHEN WE
ACTIVATE THESE DIFFERENT
EMERGENCY PROTECTIVE MEASURES OF
WHICH ONE IS COOLING CENTERS.
I'M DALY THEY ARE NOT THE END
ALL SALE ALL SOLUTION. THERE ARE
OTHER STATE. BASED ON BASE ON
THE- THEY DEPLOY OF OTHER
RESOURCE- GOING OFF OF ONE OF
OUR PREVIOUS- AS- TESTIMONIES
TODAY. YOU KNOW THEY THEY COUNTY
WORKS IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
CITIES ON THE SCHOOLING CENTER
PROGRAM A LOT OF THEM ARE AT.
FACILITIES THAT HAVE. OTHER
TYPES OF PROGRAMS ASSOCIATED
WITH THEM SO THEY ARE GETTING A
LOT MORE BENEFIT THAN JUST- COOL
AIR SO A LOT OF THE COUNTY SITES
ARE OUT OF LIBRARIES. A LOT OF
CITY SITES OR IN. AREAS OR PARKS
AND REC FACILITIES THAT INCLUDES
YOU KNOW ACCESS TO INTERNET-
POTENTIALLY FOOD. BEING PROVIDED
THERE AND PROGRAMMING TO SUPPORT
THEM SO THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED AT
THE SITE. SO THE SECOND PART OF
THE QUESTION SENATOR IS HOW
MANY. IT'S REALLY A BROAD
STROKE- WE USUALLY HAVE MORE
THAN A FEW DOZEN ACTIVATED- IF
IT'S A WIDESPREAD EVENT. AND
PROPORTIONALLY WE SEE USUALLY A
VERY SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ACTUALLY USING THAT RESOURCE.
AND I THINK THE HIGHEST USE OF
THOSE RESOURCES WAS ACTUALLY
DURING KOBE WHEN WE HAD ONE OF
OUR- KEY EVENTS DURING THAT-
MOST RESTRICTIVE PERIOD OF TIME
DURING THE STATE'S DROUGHT HOME
ORDERS. AND THERE WERE REALLY NO
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IN THE COUNTY IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE USE. THEIR NORMAL KIND
OF. GO TO PLACES FOR RELIEVING
THEMSELVES OF SOME OF THAT HE
IMPACTS ARE GOING TO SHOPPING
CENTRES AND MALLS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT OUTDOOR RECREATION AT
THE OCEAN- AND SO WHEN ALL OF
THAT STUFF IS UP AND FUNCTIONING
WE USUALLY SEE YOU KNOW PRETTY
PRETTY MODERATE LEVELS OF-
ATTENDANCE AT AT THE- AT THE
GOVERNMENT RUN- SITES. AND WOULD
YOU SAY I MEAN TO THE GOVERNMENT
RUN SAY- COUNTY FAIRGROUND OR A
COUNTY LIBRARY OR YOU KNOW CITY
COMMUNITY CENTER OR EVEN. I MEAN
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS THIS
PROPOSAL AROUND RESILIENCE HAVE
WHICH IS SORT OF A- PUBLIC
PRIVATE COMMUNITY BASED MY- BUT
IN TERMS OF HOW YOU ACTUALLY
CHECK ON PEOPLE AT HOME FOR
THOSE PEOPLE GEN. DON'T WANT TO
LEAVE HOMEOR WHO MAY NOT
OTHERWISE BE ON THE RADAR MIGHT
NOT SHOW UP AT ONE OF THE
CENTERS HOW DO YOU ACTUALLY.
WHAT IS THE WHAT WAS THE SAFE
CHECK LOOK LIKE DO YOU POORLY
FOR EXAMPLE- YOUR PAYCHECK BEST
OR YOUR WEAK DATA. OR SSI. IN
CORAL DAD SAY WITH THAT HEAT MAP
AT THE TOP AND TO SORT OF. FIND
IF WAYS GET INTO WITH PEOPLE AND
MAKE SURE THEY'RE OKAY. YES AND
THANKS FOR BRINGING THAT UP-
DEFINITELY AND- OUR LEAD.
DEPARTMENT IN THAT AFTER IS
THROUGH OUR DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC. SOCIAL SERVICES AND ON
THIS ACTUALLY CAME UP IN ONE OF
THE MORE RECENT HEAT WAVES- WHEN
THERE WAS COORDINATION BETWEEN
YOU KNOW YOUR OFFICE AND ARE
SUPERVISED ONE OF OUR
SUPERVISORS OFFICES. IT ABOUT
THIS VERY TOPIC AND WE WERE ABLE
TO NECW BACKWARDS. DID NOT WE
WERE ABLE TO. AT A MAKE SURE
THAT- YOU CONTINUES ON SO THAT'S
BEEN A STANDING PRACTICE WITHIN
THE COUNTY FOR YEARS IT'S A PART
OF THAT EXTREME TEMPERATURE PLAN
AND WE UTILIZE THOSE DIFFERENT-
FORTY DEVELOP DATABASES THAT
HAVE A TIENE WITH. OUR COUNTY
DEPARTMENT TO INITIATE OUT
THROUGH CASE WORKERS IN THAT WE
COORDINATE WITH. IN CALIFORNIA
AT A SCENE ON THEIR VULNERABLE
POPULATION DATABASES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE COMMUNICATIONS
THAT THEY'RE PUSHING OUT.
BECAUSE THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
OVERLAP WHEN THESE EVENTS OCCUR
THAT THERE'S MOST LIKELY ALSO
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER START UPS
OCCURRING- AND HEIGHTENED FIRE
WEATHER SO WE REALLY HAVE
ELEVATED OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS- AND PUT AN EMPHASIS ON.
IMPLEMENTING THESE BROADER
COORDINATION ROLES WITH
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY. BUT ON
EVERY IN ANY GIVEN EVENT TO ME
HOW HOW MANY PEOPLE DOES THAT
MEAN YOU ACTUALLY MIGHT HAVE TO
GET IN TOUCH WITH YOU KNOW ON A
ON A ON A BIG DO SO LIKE WE TALK
ABOUT THE 121 DEGREES DAY RIGHT
IF ALL SYSTEMS ARE FUNCTIONING
THE RIGHT WAY AND IT'S- IT'S ONE
TWENTY ONE IN CANOGA PARK. I
DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW IT'S
PROBABLY SOMETHING THAT INTO A
COMA AND IN THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY SO NEEDS LIKE YOU SAID A
HUGE REACH. COULD THERE BE A DAY
WHERE YOU'RE HAVING IT. YOU'RE
LITERALLY HAVING TO REACH OUT TO
LIKE A MILLION PEOPLE AT THEIR
HOMES ON ANY GIVEN DAY AND SORT
OF. DOING SOME KIND OF WELLNESS
CHECK I MEAN I JUST THINK ABOUT
HOW. HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ON SOME
KIND OF SOCIAL SERVICES. OR
DISABILITY. YOU KNOW WITHIN A
COUNTY OF. ELEVEN MILLION YOU'VE
GOT. ON ANY GIVEN DAY HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE. SO I
MEAN IF YOU FOUND THROUGH THESE
PAST HEAT WAVES THAT THEIR
BOTTLENECKS WITH THAT INTERFACE
AND WHAT CAN WE DO TO SORT OF
IMPROVE. SO IT'S NOT JUST THE
TWEET- THE ALERT. BUT IT'S LIKE
IT'S GOT THAT THAT LEVEL OF
SECURITY THAT WE SEE SAY FROM.
US YOU KNOW LIKE YOU SAY WITH
THE SS THE SOCIAL WORKER
THEMSELVES IS. MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S SOME INTERFACE AND THAT.
THEY CAN AND GET- YOU KNOW. SOME
KIND OF TECHNOLOGY FROM THE
UTILITY OR TO BRING THINGS TO
THE HOMES LIKE HOW. HAVE YOU
SEEN THAT MITIGATION. AND
RESPONSE IN ACTION. YEAH SO I
MEAN I CAN FOLLOW UP WITH DAY
WITH THE COMMITTEE WITH SOME.
DETAILED RESPONSES TODAY TO THE
NUMBERS. I DON'T HAVE THAT OFF
THE OFF THE CUFF RIGHT NOW- AS
IT RELATES TO THE SECOND PART I
THINK THERE'S DEFINITELY STILL
ADDITIONAL WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE. AS IT RELATES TO ENSURING
THAT WERE EFFECTIVELY
COMMUNICATING OUT TO. ALL THOSE
VARIOUS- VARIOUS GROUPS. WHAT
WE'VE WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING AND
I THINK IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF
THE CONTINUE CONVERSATION. IS
ENSURING THAT WE ARE LOOKING FOR
THE RIGHT. THE RIGHT POPULATION
GROUP. MEANING THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION AND NOT
JUST PULLING FROM DATABASES AND
SAYING LIKE EVERYONE WITHIN THIS
DATABASE NEEDS TO BE.
COMMUNICATED TO BASED ON BASED
ON. AN EVENT OCCURRING WHERE
THEY GEOGRAPHICALLY ARE LOCATED-
WE HAVE TO BE VERY BECAUSE OF
THE SIZE OF L. A. COUNTY WE HAVE
TO BE VERY. I THOUGHT. D. AND
HOW. WATCHING THE IS DATA POINTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE- EVEN IF
IN I GETTING THE RIM TO THE TO
THE MOST- IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAVE
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO YOU-
GET THROUGH THAT THAT OF
EMERGENCY AS BEST AS THEY CAN.
THANK YOU FOR THE INSIGHT AND
FOR THE FOR IN ADVANCE FOR ANY
FOLLOW UP YOU CAN PROVIDE YOUR-
CASE TURN TO MISS CASTILLO FOR A
QUICK SECOND HERE AND WANTED YOU
TO JUST TAKE A QUICK. SECOND TO
. GIVE US A LITTLE MORE INSIGHT
ON THIS- FOR MOST THE RENTERS
OUT THERE WHO WERE DEALING WITH-
SUB STANDARD LIVING CONDITIONS.
IS CAN YOU CAN YOU JUST
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
YOUR POINTS SO. IF I'M A TENANT-
AND- I LIVE IN A UNIT THAT HAS
AN AIR CONDITIONING UNIT BUT THE
FILTER ON ITS BUSTED AND THEY
CAN'T GET DOWN TO SEVENTY TWO
AND- YOU SORT OF JUST KNOW THAT
AND- MAYBE YOU'VE GOT A BOX FAN
BUT- YOU BASICALLY LIVE. IN
80 DEGREES HEAT FOR WEEKS ON
END- INSIDE THE HOUSE WHICH I
KNOW IS THE CASE FOR- MANY MANY.
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE
ESPECIALLY IN OVERCROWDED
HOUSING- WEIRD THERE'S EVEN LESS
SPACE BUT THERE'S NO RECOURSE
UNDER LANDLORD TENANT LAW
CURRENTLY UNDER THEIR WARRANTY
OF HABITABILITY OR ANY KIND OF
CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATION TO
PROVIDE. THAT KIND OF- OF.
HABITABLE LIVING CONDITION WHEN
IT COMES TO THE ACTUAL
TEMPERATURE. THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT AND I THINK YOU KNOW
WESTERN CENTER AND HER
COLLEAGUES ARE ADVOCATING FOR A
COST A POLICY SOLUTION BUT ALSO.
SETTING WHICH IS WE NEED TO HAVE
RENTAL HOUSING BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN AND AN INDOOR AIR
TEMPERATURE AND FOR HEATING IT.
HAS BEEN LONG RECOGNIZED AS A
HABITABILITY STANDARDS SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE CURRENT HABITABILITY
CODES AND THE HOME IS. A
STANDARD IF THEY DO NOT HAVE.
MEANS FOR CHEATING AND THE
BUILDING CODE STANDARDS
COMMISSION HAS ADOPTED THOSE
REGULATIONS TO IMPLEMENT THAT
AND SAYING THAT. HOMES MUST BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN A MINIMUM ROOM
AT. TEMPERATURE OF SEVENTY
DEGREES- AT LEAST THREE FEET OFF
THE GROUND BUT THERE IS NO
HIGHER AND MAX LIMITS. TO THAT
AND SO WHAT WE FIND IS THAT NO
TENANTS DON'T REALLY HAVE THE
RECOURSE IF THEIR HOME IS
INCREDIBLE CREDIBILITY- HI. JUST
SAY. WHY CAN'T MY IN MY RENTAL
UNIT BE COOL- THERE'S NO COOLING
MECHANISM IN A RENTAL HOME AND
SO I THINK ONE THING THAT WE'VE
BEEN SEEING ACROSS. THE UNITED
STATES AND NOT NECESSARILY FOCUS
ON RESILIENCY BUT THERE'S BEEN A
MUCH MORE FOCUSED ON THE FACT
THAT. YOU KNOW WE NEED TO BE
PROTECTING OUR HOMES AND
HABITABILITY IS HUGE SO THAT IS
OUT OF NEW YORK RELATED TO THAT
RECENT FIRE THAT HAPPENED IN
JUST THE TRAGEDIES THAT WE'VE
SEEN. AS SHOWING THAT LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND LOW INCOME
FOLKS IN GENERAL HAVE TO
WITHSTAND- A LOT MORE ISSUES IN
THEIR OWN HOMES. AND WE BELIEVE.
A SIMPLE SOLUTION WOULD JUST
NEED TO HAVE AN UPWARDS CAP OF
WHAT. CAN BE AN AMBIENT
TEMPERATURE WITHIN YOUR HOME
THAT AND THEREFORE IF WE HAVE
THAT UPWARDS CAP. ATTENDANT CAN
THEN YOU KNOW REACH OUT TO A
CODE INSPECTOR AND SAY MY HOME
HAS BEEN. OVER THIS YOU KNOW A
HUNDRED DEGREES THIS MANY DAYS
IN A ROW AND IT'S INCREDIBLY
DANGEROUS- SO OVERALL IT IS A
POLICY SOLUTION AND THE VALUE.
THAT WE MUST MAINTAIN AN AMBIENT
TEMPERATURE AND INFOSYSTEMS-
THANK YOU FOR THAT M. WE'LL BE
FOLLOWING UP ON THAT ISSUE WITH
YOU- BIT BEFORE WE WRAP THIS ONE
I DIDN'T WANT TO COME BACK- TO
MISTER OF ALL- WHEN YOU'RE IN
YOUR RESILIENCE HUB CONCEPT IN
THE PROPOSAL. HOW MUCH OF THIS
DO YOU DO YOU SORT OF ENVISION
IS A NEW BUILT INFRASTRUCTURE
AND HOW MUCH OF IT IS. TRYING TO
SORT OF. GO THAT IS RIGHT DOWN
PUT IT HE SAID. YOU KNOW PEOPLE
GO TO WHERE THE BIG PLACE THEY
ALREADY KNOW YOU KNOW THEY'VE
GOT THEIR STOP AND MAYBE A IS
THE GROWTH. STORE BUT IF
THERE'S- ARE YOU LOOKING AT
EXISTING- EITHER PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE YOU KNOW IF
IT'S THE COUNTY LIBRARY BUT ON
STEROIDS WHERE IT'S NOT JUST A
LIBRARY BUT HAS SOCIAL SERVICES
HAS A COMMUNITY CENTER HAS. PUT
SO HOW MUCH OF THIS IS YOU SORT
OF. NEW GREENFIELD SPACES AND
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT YOUR
PROPOSAL HOW MUCH OF IT IS
TRYING TO SORT OF IDENTIFY
EXISTING ASSETS AND SEE IF WE
CAN DO RETROFITS ARE SORT OF
IMPROVE ON THEM. HE JUST
ELABORATE ON THAT A LITTLE BIT.
YEAH HAPPY TO THANKS FOR THAT
QUESTION- IT IT'S- WE'RE TAKING
A BOAT AND STRATEGY SO IN SOME
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY THINKING
ABOUT THE BAY AREA IN OAKLAND
AND RICHMOND WHERE WHERE WHERE
CAN I THINK. WILL REALLY BE
ABOUT BOLSTERING RETROFITTING
EXISTING COMMUNITY INSTITUTIONS
AND BUILDINGS. LIKE LIBRARIES
YOUTH AND SENIOR CENTER IS
NONPROFIT. AND ALSO THOSE
CRITICAL ON A PUBLIC FACILITIES
THAT ARE OWNED BY THE CITY OR
COUNTY AND MISTER MACALLAN WAS
SHARING SO. IN SOME CASES IT IS
SORT OF THEIR COLLABORATION
WITH. PUBLIC COMMUTE. THROUGH
PUBLIC COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AS
YOU WERE SAYING AND SOMETIMES
SOMETIMES THAT A NONPROFIT.
RATHER FACILITY BUT- WE REALLY
DO WANT TO INVEST AT AND SORT
OF- BOLSTERED THAT KIND OF
EXISTING BUILDINGS THAT ALREADY
EXIST. IN MANY WAYS ARE
OPERATING ON A TIGHT BUDGET. AND
HAVE DETERIORATING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT NEED DEEP
REPAIRS- AND UPGRADES- HOWEVER
WE'RE KNOWLEDGE IN WORKING WITH
PARTNERS. THAT WRE UNITED IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THAT FOR SOME COMMUNITY
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE NEED TO
ALSO GO BEYOND IN. BECAUSE
THERE'S NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL
MODEL CALIFORNIA IS SUCH A
DIVERSE STATE. IN SOME
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY RURAL
AREAS THEY MAY NEED PROPERTY
UPGRADES AND NEW CONSTRUCTION.
OR THESE BUILDING THEMSELVES TO
BE CREATED AND SO WE WANT TO
CREATE FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE
THAT COMMUNITIES. ARE REALLY DRY
AND WHAT THOSE FACILITY WHERE
THOSE FACILITIES ARE LOCATED
WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE AND WHETHER
IT'S RETROFITTING OR NEW
CONSTRUCTION. AND MAKE SURE THAT. UNITY DRIVEN PROCESS. IN THAT
IT ACROSS THE VISION AND- OF
THESE PRO- BUT I IT NOW THAT.
GIVEN APPROACH WE SEE A CRITICAL
ROLE ROLE OF GOVERNMENT OTHER
CITY AND COUNTY- OFFICIALS TO
COLLABORATE WITH US ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE HUGE THAT OF PUBLIC
BUILDINGS AVAILABLE CHIU SORT OF
LEVERAGE WITH THEIR- PUBLIC
PROCESS HE AND INVESTED. THANKS
FOR THAT APPRECIATE THE INSIGHT-
I KNOW WILL BE- FOLLOWING US UP
ALSO WITH- MISPRONOUNCE ON ON
THE EXTREME HEAT RANKING
PROPOSAL- I KNOW THERE'S MEMBERS
OF THE ADMINISTRATION THE
WAITING BUT I WILL JUST SAY- TO
THE FOLKS AT GREEN LINING AND
EVERYONE HAS BEEN WORKING ON ON
THAT EFFORT AS WELL AS YOUR- LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION AND%
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMMING WILL BE
LEANING ON YOUR EXPERTISE- IN
THE WEEKS AND MONTHS TO COME
HERE SO. SAID TO ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR SIGNING IN AND WE
DO APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY-
LET'S GO TO OUR FINAL PANEL
WHICH WILL BE A SHORT ONE AND
THEN WE'LL WE'LL TURN TO PUBLIC
COMMENT BUT- SHORT PANEL BUT
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT PEOPLE- SO
WITH US WE HAVE. SOME OF THE TOP
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WORK FOR
SAFETY OFFICIALS IN THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- SO FIRST WE
HAVE DOCTOR WROTE HAN
RADHAKRISHNA WHO IS BOTH A
PUBLIC HEALTH- AND HE'S THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY WITHIN CITY PH OUR
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH-
ALONGSIDE. DR RATHER. WE ALSO
HAVE- DIP DEBRA LEE WHO'S THE
DEPUTY CHIEF SAFETY. OFFICER FOR
DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH
AND SAFETY ALSO KNOWN AS CAL
OSHA- AS WELL AS- DAVID HORNUNG
WHO HANDLES THE HEAT AGRICULTURE
PROGRAMMING- AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS- SO
LET'S START OFF WITH YOU DR
RADHAKRISHNAN AND- PLEASE TAKE
IT AWAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHAIR STERN VICE CHAIR RODRIGUEZ
AND MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TODAY. MY NAME IS
ROSE ANOTHER TRADITIONALLY
SERVED AS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
CDPH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH LEADING ITS
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY. BEGIN
BY DESCRIBING SOME OF THE HEALTH
IMPACTS AND EXTREME HEAT
EXPOSURE. THEN DESCRIBE HOW CDPH
PROVIDE SUPPORT DURING EXTREME
HEAT EVENTS THROUGH SEVERAL
PROGRAMS AND FINALLY WILL GIVE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE RECENTLY
PROPOSED BUDGET I AM ON
SURVEILLANCE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH COLLABORATIVELY
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE PARTNERS.
MANY OF THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
INCLUDING OUR MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATOR HAVE NOTED THAT
TREMENDOUS HEALTH IMPACTS OF
HEAT SOME ARE SILENT SOME ARE
INVISIBLE HE GOES BEYOND CRAMPS
AND RASHES INSTRUCTOR EXHAUSTION
AND DEATH. IT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR MANY CAUSES
RENAL FAILURE DEHYDRATION MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES DIABETES IT
INCREASES ADVERSE BIRTH OUTCOMES
SUCH AS PRETERM BIRTH AND LOW-BIRTH WEIGHT. WHAT PEOPLE DON'T
REALIZE IS THAT ALSO INCREASES
AND WORSENS MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS INCLUDING SELF INJURY
AND SUICIDE AS WELL AS
UNINTENTIONAL INJURY IN
HOMICIDE. WAVES AND DROUGHTS
ALSO IMPACT VECTOR BORNE FOOD
BORNE WATERBORNE IN SOIL BORNE
INFECTIOUS DISEASE WE HAVE SEEN
AN INCREASE IN HEAT RELATED
ILLNESS AND DEATH. CLIMATE
CHANGE AFFECTS EVERY CALIFORNIAN
BUT SOME COMMUNITIES AND
INDIVIDUALS MORE THAN OTHERS AS
NOTED BY MANY OF OUR PREVIOUS
WITNESS. EXISTING HEALTH
CONDITIONS THOSE INADEQUATELY
HOUSED OUTDOOR WORKERS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS
THE YOUNG THE ELDERLY PREGNANT
TO THOSE WITH DISABILITIES THOSE
WITH LOW INCOMES AND THOSE WHO
ARE SOCIALLY ISOLATED EXPERIENCE
DISPROPORTIONATE HARM. NEXT I'D
LIKE TO DESCRIBE CD PEACHES
RESPONSE DURING EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS WHICH TOUCHES ON MULTIPLE
DIVISIONS WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT
INCLUDING EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
OVERSIGHT OF HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH.
AND CLAMOR CHANGING MCCARTY.
FIRST CDPH IS ENVIRONMENTAL
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS OFFICE
DISSEMINATES INFORMATION TO
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
EMERGENCY NETWORKS IN
COORDINATES COMMUNICATIONS
THROUGH. THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
ALERT NETWORK. THIS OFFICE ALSO
PROVIDES FACT SHEETS AND WEB
BASED CONTENT FOR THE PUBLIC IT
INCLUDES INFORMATION FOR
PRIORITY POPULATIONS LIKE THE
ELDERLY AND THE ON HOW. SECOND
CDPH BECAUSE OF LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM THAT
SUPPORTS THE SAFETY AND
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR PATIENTS
AND RESIDENTS OF FACILITIES THAT
LICENSES DURING HEAT RELATED
EMERGENCIES. BE ADVISED
FACILITIES ON BEST PRACTICES AND
PROCEDURES MONARCHY RELATED
OCCURRENCES AND INVESTIGATE
COMPLAINTS. THIRD CD PH HAS AN
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH BRANCH THAT
TRACKS DATA ON OCCUPATIONAL HEAT
RELATED EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
VISITS USING HOSPITAL
ADMINISTRATIVE DATA ENTRY
RELATED ILLNESSES REPORTED TO
THE CALIFORNIA WORKERS
COMPENSATION INFORMATION SYSTEM
. THE DEPARTMENT MAY REFER
WORKERS OR FILE A COMPLAINT WITH
CAL OSHA IF THEY BECOME AWARE OF
THE HEAT ON THE SITUATION YOU'LL
HEAR MORE FROM THOSE COLLEAGUES
. FINALLY C. P. HAS A CLIMATE
CHANGE AND HEALTH EQUITY SECTION
WHICH I OVERSEE THAT MAINTAINS
THE CLIMATE CHANGE AND HEALTH
VULNERABILITY INDICATORS WHICH
INCLUDES PROJECTED FUTURE
EXTREME HEAT DAYS BY CENSUS
TRACT AND COUNTY. WITHIN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS BASED ON
TEMPERATURES FROM CLIMATE MODELS
DEVELOPED CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
ASSESSMENT. THE DATA IS
AVAILABLE THROUGH AN ONLINE
MAPPING PLATFORM TO PROJECT
EXTREME HEAT DAYS AND OTHER
VULNERABILITY INDICATORS AS WELL
AS A DOCTOR THE PASADENA. WE
ALSO PROVIDE TECHNICAL INPUT ON
THE CALIFORNIA HE ASSESSMENT
TOOL CHAT AND THAT WAS FUNDED
THROUGH THE FOURTH ASSESS. WHICH
PROVIDES HISTORICAL AND
PROJECTED DATA LUNCH HE SAYS
IT'S A MAPPING PLATFORM THAT
PROVIDES DATA ON FUTURE HE RISKS
AND IDENTIFIES VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND PROVIDES
RESOURCES FOR ACTION. DATA ON
HEAT RELATED ILLNESSES AND
DEATHS ARE MADE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE CHIU SEX FIRST AT THE
CENTER CDPH IS INJURY AND
VIOLENCE PREVENTION BRANCH
PUBLISHES DATA ON CALIFORNIA'S
HEAT RELATED DEATHS ON THE
CENTER WHICH IS A DATA QUERY
WEBSITE. ALLOWS USERS TO CREATE
TABLES FOR A VARIETY OF TOPICS
INCLUDING HEAT RELATED DEATHS A
YEAR. JOHN T. AGE AND RACE AND
ETHNICITY. SECOND TRACKING
CALIFORNIA. DATA ON DEATHS
HOSPITALIZATIONS EMERGENCY
VISITS. RELATED ILLNESS ARE ALSO
AVAILABLE THROUGH TRACKING
CALIFORNIA'S WEBSITE REASON
USERS CAN VIEW A NUMBER OF RAPES
BY COUNTY YEAR AGE SEX. RACE AND
ETHNICITY THIS IS A PROGRAM
FUNDED BY THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE. THROUGH THE CDC'S
NATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC
HEALTH RACKING PROGRAM IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CDPH. FINALLY
I'D LIKE TO MENTION AS PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET A PROPOSAL
TO INITIATE SURVEILLANCE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA TO BETTER DETECT
CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED HEALTH
OUTCOMES EARLY IN NEAR REAL TIME
TO PLAN AND MOBILIZE LOCAL FIRST
RESPONDERS AND OTHER RESOURCES
TO REACH VULNERABLE PEOPLE AND
PREVENT FURTHER ILLNESS INJURY
OR DEATH. THE PRIMARY MECHANISM
FOR EARLY DETECTION OF CLIMATE
CHANGE RELATED HEALTH CONDITIONS
WILL BE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL'S BIO
SENSE NATIONAL SYNDROMIC
SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM AND S. S.
P. STAFF WOULD WORK WITH
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT FACILITIES
IN CALIFORNIA REPORTING HEALTH
SURVEILLANCE DATA TO ENROLL AND
TRAIN THEM. TO REPORT RELATED IN
THE STATE AT PROVIDING INTENSIVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT. EVERY CHIEF COMPLAINT
AND DISCHARGE DIAGNOSIS FROM AN
ENROLLED EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
WOULD ENSURE THE SYSTEM WITHIN
ABOUT TWENTY FOUR HOURS THE
PATIENT IS. FUNDS WOULD BE USED
TO HELP UPGRADE SYSTEMS FOR DATA
REPORTING ANALYSIS DISPLAY
COMMUNICATIONS AUTOMATED DATA
TRANSFER ANALYSIS AND SHARING AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE WITH STATE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND THE
PUBLIC. SYSTEM COULD ALSO BE
USED FOR A VARIETY OF OTHER
HEALTH OUTCOMES OUTSIDE OF SHE
IN OUTSIDE OF CLIMATE RELATED
CONDITIONS. CURRENTLY CDPH CAN
ONLY PROVIDE TRACKING OF HEAT
RELATED HEALTH OUTCOMES WITH THE
WAGON TIME ABOUT ONE YEAR.
SYNDROMIC SURVEILLANCE WOULD
PROVIDE NEAR REAL TIME DATA TO
IDENTIFY HEAT ILLNESSES WITH THE
GOAL OF MONITORING TRACKING IN
ORDER TO ULTIMATELY RESPOND
QUICKLY BUT ULTIMATELY PERFECT.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD UTILIZE THE
EXISTING BIOSENSOR PLATFORM OF
THE CDC AND RESULTS WOULD START
TO BE SEEN WITHIN THE YEAR AFTER
THE PROGRAM IS SET UP INDEED
AGREEMENTS ARE SIGNED HOWEVER IT
WILL REQUIRE TIME TO REACH ON
BOARD TRAIN IMPLEMENTED DATA
USER AGREEMENTS. AND PRACTICES
WITH THE FACILITIES TO BE
COMPLETE SO WE WOULD BE GETTING
BY ENROLLING THE APPROXIMATELY
FORTY FIVE FACILITIES THAT ARE
ALREADY INVOLVED ACROSS EIGHTEEN
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA. THERE'S
A SEPARATE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL AS WELL FOR ONE TIME
FUNDING OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION
TO ESTABLISH CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HEALTH RESILIENCY GRANT PLANNING
PROGRAM. IN COLLABORATION WITH
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND TRIBES AND ONE COMPONENT OF
RESILIENCE PLANS AT THE REGIONAL
LEVEL COULD BE TO COORDINATE THE
PREVENTION AND REDUCTION OF
HEALTH IMPACTS OF INCREASED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS- THANK
YOU DR- WHAT WILL COME BACK- BUT
SAID LET'S HEAR FROM OTHER TWO
PANELISTS- THINK FIRST UP WE'RE
GONNA HAVE- I SEE YOU THERE ON
THE SCREEN DAVID SO WHY DON'T
YOU GO WITH. WHAT WILL COME BACK
TO COME BACK TO DENVER IN A
MINUTE AND- YEAH LET'S HEAR FROM
DEPARTMENT INVESTOR RELATIONS
DIVISION OF. OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH
SAFETY AND WE KNOW MISTER
WORK IN HE NETWORK CULTURE-
SPECIFICALLY AND I KNOW THAT'S
BEEN AN ISSUE FOR. SMM ROB RIVAS
AND A NUMBER OF OTHERS- SO LOOK
FORTY HEARING FROM YOU SIR.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DAVID
HORNUNG I'VE WORKED AT COLLEGE
NOW FOR THIRTEEN YEARS. THE PAST
FOUR YEARS IN THE ROLE OF
CALLUSES G. IN AGRICULTURE
PROGRAM COORDINATOR. DIMINISH
YOUR DETAILS ON COLLEGES HE DOES
PREVENTION REGULATION. NOR
CALLOUS HAS BEEN DOING TO
PREVENT YOU KNOW SOMEONE
CALIFORNIA WORKS. HELLO SHOULD
MINISTERS THE LARGEST STATE
BUDGET PLAN IN THE NATION. IT'S
BEEN THE FIRST TO NOT MANY
REGULATIONS PREVENT INJURY AND
ILLNESS. THE FIRST AY TO TALK
HE DOES PREVENTION REGULATION
ACT TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
RELATIONAL FLIES TO ALL OUTDOOR
PLACES OF EMPLOYMENT REQUIRES
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE WATER IN
CHANGE FOR THEIR WORKERS. HAVE
PROCEDURES IN PLACE TO OBSERVE
NEW WORKERS WORKING AND HE- HOW
TO MERGING SEA RESPONSE
PROCEDURES IN CASE WORK BECOMES
L. IN IN CERTAIN INDUSTRIES SUCH
AS AGRICULTURE CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS MUST HAVE HIGH HEAT
PROCEDURES FOR THE WINTER. WHEN
TEMPERATURES ARE ABOVE NINETY
FIVE. TEMPERATURES IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO INCREASING EACH
SUMMER WE SEE AND EXPERIENCE NEW
RECORD HIGHS. CALLUSES BEEN
PROACTIVE IN ADDRESSING THE
HAZARD KEEPERS OUTREACH
CONSULTATION IN ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CALLOUSLY BEGAN WORK
ON AN INDOOR T. ROWE MAKING TAX
. REMAKING IS COMPLEX. OUR
COMMANDER HE PACKAGE HAS
INCLUDED MEDIAN VISOR COMMITTEE
AND HOLDING THREE PUBLIC
MEETINGS TO SOLICIT STAKEHOLDER
INPUT ALONG WITH A COMPLETE IN
ECONOMIC IMPACT STATEMENT KNOWN
AS ASTORIA. LAST OCTOBER WE'RE
ABLE TO SEND COMPLETED ROAMING
COMPACTORS OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH STANDARDS BOARD WHICH
INDEPENDENT BODY THAT SETS
STANDARDS WITHIN THOSE A PROGRAM
. AT THIS POINT THE STANDARDS
BOARD IS REVIEWING THAT
RULEMAKING PACKAGE WILL BE
PROVIDING FEEDBACK TO OSHA. THE
DALLAS AT FOUR RUBIO. THIS
REGULATIONS CAN BE VERY HELPFUL
TO HELP INSURE ALL WORKERS THOSE
WORKING BOTH INDOORS AND
OUTDOORS ARE PROTECTED FROM HEAT
ILLNESS. SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN
CALLUSES LETTER HE DOES
PREVENTION PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO EDUCATE
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS. THE
WATERSHED REST CAMPAIGN INCLUDES
RADIO AND BILLBOARD ADS IN PRINT
TRAINING MATERIALS AVAILABLE
FROM NINETY NINE FLOOR NOT WORK
. IN TWENTY TWENTY STARTED
TAPPING INTO SOCIAL MEDIA
AMPLIFY HE'D ALMOST AWARENESS.
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS
RESULTED IN OVER ONE MILLION
UNIQUE AVENUES. LAST YEAR WE
DEPLOYED LABOR RIGHTS CARAVANS
IMPORTED EFFORTWITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE UNITY.
PUBLIC SERVICE MESSAGING
BROADCAST MESSAGES MULTIPLE
LANGUAGE LANGUAGES. CALLUSES
CONSULTATION SERVICE HELPS
EMPLOYERS COMPLY WITH COLLEGES
SAFETY AND HEALTH REGULATIONS
THESE SERVICES REDUCE AND
ELIMINATE WORKPLACE INJURIES AND
ILLNESSES VOLUNTARY COMPLIANCE
AND BEST PRACTICE IMPROVEMENTS.
LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED ONSITE CONSULTATIONS
THAT INCLUDED KEYNOTES
PREVENTION. HELLO CAL TELL US
ALSO HAS A DEDICATED OUR REGION
OF THE PERFORMED I REACHED YOUR
FORMAL TRAININGS WORKSHOPS
SEMINARS SPEECHES INFORMATION
NEWS THE CARAVANS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED. CALLOUS HAS MANY
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO EMPLOYERS
AND WORKERS SUCH AS TRAINING
SUPPORT MATERIALS NUMEROUS
FACTIONS AND IF HE DOES
PREVENTION MODEL PROGRAM. ROB
WAS LOOKING FOR WAYS TO REACH
LEADERS AND ADVOCATES IN YOUR
COMMUNITY TAMPA FIRE SAFETY
MESSAGING. HI TO ALL OF OUR
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS FREE OF
CHARGE SO PLEASE DON'T HESITATE
TO REACH OUT TO OUR OFFICE. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME NOMINEE
HANDED OVER TO DEBRA LEE.
CALLUSES SB CHIEF OF ENFORCEMENT
NEVER. GET AFTERNOON CHAIRMEN
AND STERN AND VICE CHAIRMAN.
RODRIGUEZ AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH YOU
ABOUT HOW WE SHOULD WORK TO
PROTECT WORKERS FROM SHE WOULD
NEED IT HASN'T MY NAME IS
BEVERLY I SERVED AS THE DEPUTY
CHIEF OF ENFORCEMENT FOR
TOWNSHIP I BEGAN MY CAREER WITH
CAL OSHA OVER TWENTY NINE YEARS
AGO WHEN I STARTED AS AN
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENIST. THIS WAS
MENTIONED BY MY COMPLICATED.
CALIFORNIA WITH THE NATION MY
NOT BE ENOUGH FOR. HE STANDARD
TO PROTECT OUTDOOR WORKERS. IT
PROVIDES BACKGROUND. HELLO
SHOULD INITIATE INVESTIGATIONS
AND THREE RIGHT. ONE THROUGH THE
COMPLAINT PROCESS WORKERS ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN CONTENT
WHATEVER SEVENTEEN HOW OCEAN
DISTRICT AND FORCE IN OFFICES TO
LODGE A COMPLAINT. LAST YEAR THE
DIVISION LAUNCHED A WORKER
RESOURCE CENTER WHAT WORKERS CAN
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT. NINETEEN HE
WILDFIRE SMOKE. AND THE
COMPLAINT PROCESS. THIRTY YEARS
RIGHT THIS SECOND IS ARE REPORTS
OF WORKPLACE INJURIES AND
ILLNESSES BY LAW EMPLOYERS ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT ANY WORKPLACE
RELATED INJURIES ILLNESSES OR
DEATH ACCOUNT OSHA INCLUDING
THOSE RELATED TO EXTREMES AND
EXPOSURE. THE THIRD IS THROUGH.
APPLE APPLE INVESTIGATION THESE
ARE TARGETED INSPECTIONS OF
INTERSTATES WHERE THERE IS A
HEIGHTENED RISKS OF INJURY AND
ILLNESSES AND INJURIES TO
WORKERS. AB ARE IN FOR STATE
EFFORTS WE DEVELOP A SPECIAL
INTERESTS THIS PROGRAM SHOULD
DRESS HOUSEHLDS THIS INCLUDES
ENHANCED INSPECTION PROTOCOLS
WHEN RESPONDING TO REPORTS OF
HEAT RELATED ILLNESSES AND
COMPLAINTS COLLEGE IT DOESN'T
WAIT FOR THE TEMPERATURE TO
REACH A CERTAIN NUMBER. IN ORDER
TO CONDUCT HIGH HEAT INSPECTION-
CARRIED OUT TARGETED IN FORCE
THAT LEADS. YEARS OF HIGH TO
ENSURE EMPLOYERS ARE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE HEAT ILLNESS
PREVENTION STANDARD BETWEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE HELLO SHE CONDUCTED
ABOUT THREE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED INSPECTIONS ANNUALLY.
ZAGWE TEMPLARS COMPLIANCE WITH
THE KEEP ILLNESS PREVENTION
REGULATIONS RESULTING IN MORE
THAN TWELVE BILLION. DOLLARS IN
TOTAL PENALTIES. HELLO SHE IS
DEAD TO BRING CALIFORNIA FROM
EXTRA HEAT IN THE WORK. IN THE
COMING YEARS PLAN ON AND
EXPANDING OUR EXISTING TRACKING
MECHANISM AND REGION YOU CAN
PROCESS FOR ALL K<c.cyan> RELATED</c>
INSPECTIONS WHICH WILL HELP US
DRAW INSIGHTS ON TRENDS IN
COMPLAINTS AND REPORTED
INJURIES. AS WELL AS PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE OUR
COMPLAINT INTAKE AND OUR
INSPECTION PROCESS. WE ARE ALSO
EXPLORING WAYS TO IMPROVE OUR
COMPLAINT TRACKING PROCESS AND
INCLUDE AND THAT'S POSSIBLY
INCLUDING AUTOMATING THE SYSTEM. I WOULD ALSO STATE THAT COUNTS
ARE CURRENTLY IN SPORTS IS
INDOOR HE THREW THE TITLE EIGHT
SECTION THIRTY TWO OR THREE BY
ENSURING THAT EMPLOYERS HAVE A
PROGRAM IN PLACE THAT RECOGNIZE
THESE HOUSES. AND EFFECTIVE
INJURY AND ILLNESS PREVENTION
PROGRAM IMPROVES SAFETY AND
HEALTH IN THE WORKPLACE IT
REDUCES WORKERS INJURIES AND
ILLNESSES. STAFFING IS A
PRIORITY HELLO CHAU. DECREASING
OUR VACANCY RATE IS AND HAS BEEN
A TOP PRIORITY TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE MORE SAFETY ENGINEERS AND
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENIST IN THE
FIELD CONDUCTING INSPECTIONS. WE
HAVE MADE CONSIDERABLE PROGRESS
IN TWENTY TWENTY WE HIRED FORTY
NEW STAFF AND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THAT NUMBER TRIPLED TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY HIRES ACROSS
THE DIVISION. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO BUILD ON THIS MOMENTUM. IT
BEFORE CLOSING I LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE TINA
MOSHE WHO SHOWS THEIR DEDICATION
AND PASSION EVERY DAY TO KEEP
CALIFORNIANS SAFE AND WORK. AND
IT IS AN HONOR TO BE A PART OF
THIS ORGANIZATION AND I
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK WITH YOU ABOUT OUR WORK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
DAVID AND I ARE AVAILABLE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
DEFINITELY. I WOULD APPRECIATE
IT- MY FIRST QUESTION IS FOR-
ACTUALLY- DR RADHAKRISHNAN IF
YOU'RE STILL WITHUS WE'D MAYBE
CAN COME BACK TO THE I. R. N. AS
IN A MOMENT HERE BUT- YOU KNOW
THERE'S BEEN. BEEN A NUMBER OF
REPORTS AND- IN SOME FRUSTRATION
AROUND THE DATA THAT I THINK YOU
YOU ACTUALLY WENT. VERY USEFUL
INSIGHT ON. ESPECIALLY AS YOU
SORT OF GIVE A LITTLE MORE
DETAIL ABOUT. WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PLANS. IS LOOKING
LIKE FOR THIS COMING YEAR AND A
BIT OF THE CENTRAL ISSUE AROUND
LAG TIME IN TERMS OF REAL TIME
DATA VERSUS- SORT OF RETRO SPECK
A RETROACTIVE DATA- YOU KNOW THE
REPORTS WE SAW IS THAT- WE HAD
REPORTS OF HEAT RELATED DEATHS
IN THE HUNDREDS OVER A DECADE. I
THINK THAT THE NUMBERS FIVE
HUNDRED NINETY DEATHS BUT THAT-
WHEN YOU TAKE A DEEPER LOOK AT
THE NUMBERS AND HOW PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY AND BEING IMPACTED THE
NUMBERS REALLY IN THE- THE MANY
THOUSANDS- HEY WE REMEDY THAT
THAT SORT OF. THAT COUNTING- GAP
IT IN TERMS OF HOW WE ACTUALLY
GET TO THE DATA AND IS NOW THE
QUESTION OF HOW FAST WE CAN GET
THAT DATA TO THE PUBLIC OR IS
THERE SOME SORT OF. IS THERE A
DEEPER UNDERLYING- CHALLENGE IN
ACTUALLY- ATTRIBUTING- THESE
KIND OF HEALTH RELATED INCIDENTS
TO THE- SORT OF. EGGS YOU KNOW
AMBIENT FACTORS LIKE HEAT- LIKE
A WILD FIRE I MEAN I JUST KNOW
FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. IN
HAVING MY GRANDPARENTS EVACUATE
DURING THE WILL THE FIRE AND-
THEY SAT ON THEIR OUT OF THIS
HIGHWAY LOCKED INTO THEIR CAR
FOR EIGHT HOURS IN. THE TROM OF
THAT EVENT THEN THAT DAY LEAD MY
GRANDFATHER TO THE I SEE YOU AND
HE WASN'T REALLY SUPPOSED TO BE
MOVED AND TRANSPORTED BUT HAD TO
BE IN THAT INCIDENT SO. AND OVER
THERE I SEE YOU AND THEN THREE
MONTHS LATER BECAUSE OF RELATED
COMPLICATIONS- WE DIDN'T WE LOST
HIM AND- YOU KNOW THAT THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY ATTRIBUTE TO
SAY THAT WILDFIRE EMERGENCY BUT
I THINK OF SIMILAR SITUATIONS OF
SOMEBODY'S GOING THROUGH A
HEATING VENT. AND THEY START
HAVING HEART ISSUES BUT MAYBE IT
DOESN'T EMERGE THAT DAY OR THEY
DON'T HAVE A CATASTROPHIC STROKE
BUT SOMETHING SOMETHING CHANGES-
THAT THAT THROUGH THAT TRAUMA OF
THAT PARTICULAR. DAY OR THAT
PARTICULAR INCIDENT SO. I IS IT
IS A ABOUT IS IT REPORTING
FUNCTION THAT WE NEED TO SOLVE
OR IS THE IS THAT THAT BASIC
DIAGNOSIS SOMETHING THAT WE JUST
AREN'T. WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA
NECESSARILY IN OUR SYSTEM- TO
SHOW US AND TO SHOW THE PUBLIC
FRANKLY WHO SUFFERING. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION SENATOR STERN
AND ALSO FOR SHARING THE STORY
ABOUT YOUR GRANDFATHER IT
HIGHLIGHTS THE TRAUMA AND THE
MENTAL IMPACT. FOR THE SURVIVORS
AS WELL AS THE PERSON HARM NOT
TO MENTION THE PHYSICAL IMPACT.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN THE
CLIMATE AND HEALTH SURVEILLANCE
IS DESIGNED TO ADDRESS BOTH
ISSUES THAT YOU RAISED. ACCURACY
AND TIMELINESS AS YOU NOTED THE
CHIEF COMPLAINT WHEN SOMEONE
WALKS IN THE DISCHARGE DIAGNOSIS
WHEN SOMEBODY LEAVES WHAT'S
NOTED ON A DEATH CERTIFICATE.
MAY NOT HAVE THE WORD KEEPS
SHOWING ON BYE BYE TRIANGULATED
IN THAT INFORMATION WE CAN HAVE
MORE ACCURATE AND COMPLETE DATA
TO USE THE EXAMPLE SOMEONE MAY
COME IN WITH CODING. BUT DIED OF
ACUTE HYPOXIC RESPIRATORY
FAILURE. AND SO TO USE A BROADER
TERMS WITH THE ICD TEN
INTERNATIONAL CLASSIFICATION OF
DISEASE. CAPTURES A MORE BROADER
NET OF CONDITIONS RELATED TO
HEAT CAN ALLOW US TO BE MORE
ACCURATE IN CAPTURING THE TRUE
BURDEN. AND THEN OF COURSE
TIMELINESS IS ESSENTIAL NOT JUST
ACCOUNT MUCH TO MITIGATE INTEL
COMMITTEE PREVENT. THE PROPOSAL
THAT I DESCRIBED IS DESIGNED. TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES. THANK YOU
FOR THAT IN- AND I SURE THROUGH
THE BY PROCESS WILL BE SCRUTINY
SCRUTINIZING AND GREATER DETAIL
BUT- YOU CAN COUNT ON ME FOR-
VERY CONSTRUCTIVE ENGAGEMENT AND
I APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION THERE TO. TO
FILLING THIS GAP AND AS YOU
MENTIONED I THINK YOU SAID FORTY
FIVE FACILITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
PLUGGED INTO BIOSENSOR WILL BE
ABLE TO SHOW PEOPLE SOONER THAN
LATER AND GET THAT MOVING
QUICKLY WHILE WE BUILD OUT THE
REST OF THE DATE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND GET THOSE AGREEMENTS SIGNED
SOUNDS LIKE A- PRUDENT- WAY TO.
ATTACK THIS ISSUE- IN A TIMELY
MANNER- AS WELL SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT MY OTHER QUESTION WAS FOR.
I THINK DOCTOR LEE ALTHOUGH IT
MAY BE FOR I'M SORRY DIRECTOR
LEE AND THAT HE LEAVE OR OR
MISTER HORN ON- NANCY SENATOR
BROUGHT THIS UP ON A PAST PANEL
OR ABOUT THE CONDITIONS THAT.
DOMESTIC WORKERS FACE INDOORS-
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S THE
HISTORIC WORK THAT WAS DONE ON
SORT OF THE OUTDOOR HEAT
STANDARD- FOR EVERYONE AS THE
LABOR OUTSIDE- ELEMENTS BEEN
SUBJECT IN HUMANE- AND VERY
UNSAFE CONDITIONS BUT- WE KNOW
THERE THERE'S BEEN NO ADOPTION
OF AN INDOOR HEAT STANDARD CAN
YOU. SHARE ANY INSIGHT ON ON
THOSE ISSUES THAT THAT EFFECT-
MASTIC WORKERS LIKE MR NAGLE WAS
TALKING ABOUT- FOR- LIKE MRS
THAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT- AS THE
INDOOR CONDITIONS AT HER
WORKPLACE SAY. AT THE AMAZON
WAREHOUSE. IN DON'T HAVE YOU
START. YEAH THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I CAN ANSWER THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE ASPECT OF THE
INDOOR HEATING WHERE THAT IS IN
THE RULEMAKING PROCESS AS AS
DEBRA MENTIONED WE DO HAVE
REGULATIONS CURRENTLY WHICH WERE
ABLE TO ENFORCE TO DRESS THE
HAZARD AND INDOOR HEAT WHATEVER
IT'S NOT AS SPECIFIC AS WHAT
PERHAPS AGE REGULATIONS SPECIFIC
TO HIM OR HE- WOULD BE- THAT.
REGULATION IS IN THEIR OWN
MAKING PROCESS RIGHT NOW IT'S A
PROCESS IT'S FAIRLY COMPLEX. WE
STARTED THE ROLE MAKING PROCESS
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO WE'VE
CONVENE AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE
MEETING WITHOUT THREE PUBLIC
MEETINGS ON AT. TEN SEVEN
DIFFERENT DRAFTS THE REGULATIONS
THIS POINT. AND I'M HAPPY TO SAY
THAT IN OCTOBER AT DRAFT WAS
SENT OVER TO THE OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH STANDARDS FOR.
WHICH IS THE BODY THAT CRUZ
TALISA REGULATIONS. OUR WORK
WE'RE HOPEFUL TO GET IT BACK
FROM THEM SOON WITH COMMENTS
FROM THEM THEN WILL TAKE
ANOTHER. PASS AT IT BEFORE
SENDING IT BACK TO THEM. WHERE
THEY WILL THEN VOTE ON IT ONE OF
THEIR MONTHLY MEETINGS. AND WE
HOPE THEN IT WILL GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS PUBLIC COMMENT. AND THAT
THE PAST EVENTUALLY THROUGH THE
OFFICE ADMINISTRATOR LAN
SECRETARY OF STATE- TO BE PASSED
AND IMPLEMENTED BY US. CAN YOU
GIVE US A LITTLE BETTER SENSE
THAT ONE TIME LINE I MEAN WE
KNOW WE KNOW THIS STANDARD IS
REQUIRED BE PROMULGATED BY LAW
AND IT'S BEEN LOST ON THE BOOK
FOR. A FEW YEARS NOW- IS THAT IS
THIS YEAR KIND OF NOTICE AND
COMMENT PROCESS THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT OR YOU COULD THIS
SPENT ON- INTO TWENTY THREE. AND
UNFORTUNATELY I CAN ONLY SHARE
WITH YOU SOME OF THE TIME FRAMES
IN THE OVERALL PROCESS. CAN'T BE
ROUTED TO THE TENTATIVE DATE OF
WHEN IT WILL BE. PAST YOU KNOW
WE ARE EAGER TO HAVE A INDOOR-
HILLS PREVENTION REGULATION IT'S
IMPORTANT CALLOUS SETS AND-
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF EFFORT INTO
GETTING THE REGULATION RIGHT.
AND JUST SO I'M CLEAR THE VERY
STRAPS AND THIS SORT OF THE WAY
IT'S BEEN ITERATED RIGHT NOW. IT
IS IT'S CURRENTLY UNDER REVIEW
SO THAT'S NOT YET A PUBLIC
NOTICE ON THAT PROPOSAL BUT ONCE
THAT REVIEW IS COMPLETE THAT
INITIAL DRAFT PUBLICATION WILL
BE. YEAH WELL WILL BE THAT'LL BE
OUR FIRST ABILITY TO LOOK AT IT
THAT IS THAT ABOUT RIGHT.
ACTUALLY THAT THE DRAFT
REGULATION IS UP ONLINE RIGHT
NOW YOU CAN SEE IT ON OUR ON ALL
RULEMAKING PAGE. IT WILL GO TO
NOTICE AFTER THE STANDARDS BOARD
WHICH IS IF THEY BALK TO IMPROVE
IT. AND THAT WOULD IS WHAT WOULD
START THE FORTY FIVE DAY PUBLIC
. OKAY WELL FROM FROM JUST THIS
ONE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SENATORS
PERSPECTIVE- I WHICH YOU- AND
EXPEDITIOUS BUT STILL YOU KNOW-
THOUGHTFUL PROCESS IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'VE- TAKEN A LOT OF TIME
TO THINK IS THIS THROUGH A COULD
HAVE MASSIVE IMPLICATIONS BUT-
WE'RE REALLY COUNTING ON YOU. AT
THE PART OF INVESTOR RELATIONS
OVERALL- TO NOT JUST YOU KNOW
THINK ABOUT THE OUTSIDE BUT- IN
EVERYBODY'S HOMES AND IN THE
PLACES THAT MAYBE WE DON'T OFTEN
THINK OF- YOU KNOW THE PLACES
THAT. I'M YOU KNOW MISSING AGAIN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT SHE WORKS
FOR OUT IN SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
WHO WERE. YOU KNOW OUT OF SIGHT
AND OUT OF MINE BUT STILL HAVE
CHALLENGES SO- LOOK FORWARD TO
FEEDBACK THERE AND WILL BE
REVIEWING THE THAT DRAFT AS WE
MOVE ALONG HERE. I'M DO WE HAVE.
ANY OTHER. YESTERDAY YES THERE
WERE AT LEAST. REALLY YEAH
PLEASE JUMP. IT IS Y. TO HAVE
ONE OTHER THAT- TO ECHO MY
COWORKERS AND THAT IS COUNTY
BOARD CHILD. HELLO RECOGNIZES
THATINDOOR HE IS VERY IS A VERY
SERIOUS PASSAGE. AND AS I STATED
IN MY OPENING- WE ARE LOOKING AT
AND FORCING IN YOUR SEATS WITH
OUR THIRTY TWO OR THREE-
REGULATION. AND LOOKING AT THOSE
INDUSTRIES SUCH AS WAREHOUSES AT
OTHER MANUFACTURING AS WELL AS
FOUNDRIES AND OTHER OPERATIONS
WHERE. THE HEAT AND OR ITS
HEIGHT AND MOVING FORWARD- WE'RE
LOOKING AT AS I MENTIONED ABOUT
TARGETING CERTAIN AREAS IN
CERTAIN INDUSTRIES THAT
PRODUCES- AND COULD CONTRIBUTE-
INJURIES TO WORKERS. AND SO I
JUST WANTED TO. ENSURE THAT WE
ARE AS A TRAVEL SHOW LOOKING
AFTER. AND DOING THOSE TYPES OF.
INSPECTIONS THAT WE WILL GO IN
TO LOOK AT IT WILL BE EVALUATING
EMPLOYERS- RECOGNITION AND
IDENTIFYING OF THE STATUS OF
HAZARDS IN THEIR WORKPACE AND
WHAT ACTIONS THEY ARE TAKING TO
ADDRESS THOSE THINGS- SUCH AS
INDOOR HEAT. AT A PREVIOUS THAT
IN AND TO THE EXTENT- YOU CAN
BRING THIS COMMITTEE BACK OR
SHARE HOW THAT INSPECTION
PROCESS GOING ON I'M SURE IT
ALSO OCCURRED THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS BUT- TO SEE WHAT THOSE
IN IT THAT INITIAL ROUND OF
INSPECTIONS IS YIELDING- BOTH
THROUGH THE- YOU KNOW YOUR
PROACTIVE EFFORTS AS WELL AS
THE- THE COMPLAINT NETWORK THAT
YOU BILL- HOPEFULLY PEOPLE
ACTUALLY. TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS. OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY
HAVE THEIR VOICE HEARD FINALLY
ON THE CONDITIONS THEY ARE
FACING AND- USED THE STANDARD TO
ENSURE THEIR PUBLIC HEALTH IS
PROTECTED SO WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT- TYPICALLY- I LOOKED AT MY
CAR. FOR A FOR COMMENT REQUEST.
NO I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
ALL THE PAN FOR TAKING THE
TODAY. TO GIVE US THEIR INSIGHTS
ON ON SOME OF THE STRATEGIES
THAT WE CAN LOOK FORWARD TO IN
TRYING TO DEALING WITH HEAT.
THESE HE EMERGED EMERGENCIES AND
ALSO- KEEPING THE PUBLIC SAFE
OUT THERE- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US AS I STATED
BEFORE TO ESTABLISH A BASE
BECAUSE ALL OF THE STRATEGIES
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT DEPEND ON A
COUPLE OF RESOURCES- ONE OF THEM
BEING WATERED ONE OF BEING
ELECTRICITY- SO. IF WE DON'T TIE
THOSE TWO TOGETHER AND DO
SOMETHING ABOUT- SOME OF THE
SHORTAGES THAT WE HAVE AND-
INEFFICIENCY THAT WE HAVE IN
THOSE RESPECTS FOR THE STATE-
ALL THIS CAN BE FOR NOT SO- I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE- WORKING ON
THIS IN THE FUTURE WITH- ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES AND- BOTH THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE FINAL
NOTE AND I YOU KNOW WE HAD WE
DID HAVE A PANEL- LOOKING AT
UTILITIES IN EXTREME HEAT BOTH
ON THE WATER AND POWER SIDE OF
SUCH A PACT HEARING BUT I WILL
SAY THAT IS AN INDISPENSABLE
PART OF THE WORK AND GREATER
RESILIENCE DURING THOSE MOMENTS
WHEN HE STRAINS- YOU KNOW ARE
NOT JUST OUR TRANSMISSION SYSTEM
BUT OUR GAS PLANTS THE ABILITY
TO RAMP CYCLE DOWN. WATER
PUMPING TECHNOLOGY I'M ALL THAT
SO VERY MUCH- SHOULD BE PART OF
IN LOOKS TO BE IN THE EXTREME
HEAT STRATEGY FROM THE GOVERNOR
BUT- WILL BE HOPING FOR YOU KNOW
JUST MORE DETAIL OUT OF THAT IN
THE WEEKS TO COME SO- DO
APPRECIATE THE PANELISTS
TESTIMONY. APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
ADMINISTRATION FROM TESTIFYING
AND WITH THAT I WANT TO OPEN IT
UP TO THE PUBLIC COMMENTS SO-
LET ME SEE- I KNOW I GAVE THE
NUMBER AT THE- OUTSET- BUT- DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH O THE HEARINGS AND- ALL
THE TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATION THE
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. WE WILL HAVE
TO ASK FOR SOME TIME LIMIT ON
TESTIMONY- SO WE'RE GONNA ASK
FOR. A MINUTE EACH AT THIS
POINT. AND WE CAN BEGIN WITH
TESTIMONY FROM ANYONE WHO'S HERE
IN THE GALLERY BUT I DON'T SEE.
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN PERSON- SO
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES
POTENTIALLY WAITING ON THE-
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE TO
PROVIDE. COMMENT MODERATE IF YOU
PLEASE PROBABLY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
WE CAN GET STARTED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHARE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. ONCE AGAIN THAT'S THE
NUMBER ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
PLEASE. YOU HAVE A FEW LINES
WITH OPERATORS BE JUST A MOMENT
. IF YOU CAN GIVE US THE TOTAL
NUMBER JUST- BEFORE WE GET
STARTED. THANK YOU RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE TWO LINES IN Q. GREAT WE
CAN PROCEED. LINE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DRAGANA
MORALIS WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORT LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN THE
KEY REGIONS OF NEARLY IMPACTED
BY EXTREME HEAT EXTREME COLD THE
FINE PRINT THE LIFE WITHOUT THE
CALIFORNIA TENANTS BECAUSE THEY
LACK ADEQUATE COOLING AND WHAT
THE RADIATION IN THEIR HOMES AND
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. REPUBLICAN
VALLEY AND THE COACHELLA VALLEY
HAVE LONG BEEN NEGLECTED AND
UNDER IMPACTED EACH REGION'S
EXPERIENCE ABOVE AVERAGE HIGH
TEMPERATURES FOR SEVERAL MORE
DAYS IN OTHER REGIONS AND WHICH
WILL PERSONALLY IN THE COMING
YEARS WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE
COULD TAKE. ACTION TO RESPOND TO
ACTUALLY DO THAT I REQUIRED THAT
ALL RENTAL UNITS. IN CALIFORNIA
PROVIDING. SIMILAR TO THE
CURRENT TWO PARTIES ARE OF
HEATING. ALIVE CALL WITH MUCH
AND THAT THE TO BUILD GOVERNMENT. THANK ALLOCATE PATEL INTO CARP
. TARGET MORE BECAUSE THANK OF
COLOR. WE INVEST IN HEALTH AND
COOL HOMES PROTECT LOWER A HELLO
FROM BEING ABLE TO CALL OF ANY
AND ONE THE RIGHT THESE. CENTRIC
AND- I THINK WE THOUGH YOU CAN
EXPECT. COOLEY PENNER IN THE
DISH TO COME THE OTHER CANNELLA
BENEFIT. COLLECTIVELY WE NEED.
WILL HOLD THE ACT BUT QUITE AND
BEST THE CAL DISPROPORTIONATELY
IN. BY CLIMATE CHANGE THANK YOU
- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR A
PACKING A LOT INTO A SHORT BIT
OF TESTIMONY AND FOR YOUR WORK
IT'S LEADERSHIP COUNCIL THANK
YOU I NEXT. NEXT TO THE
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU NOTES LINE
SEVENTY TWO SEVENTY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR A HAVING THAT
RESEARCH TEARS TURNED OUT TO BE
THE TWO TREK H. R. P. HOW. OLDER
ADULTS FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
OUT. ACT OF EXTREME HEAT. BY TWO
THIRTY TEN EIGHT MILLION. WILL
BE EIGHT. FOUR OLDER WHICH BE A
QUARTER THE STATE. WE CAN'T
IGNORE THIS POPULATION
PROJECTION ESPECIALLY WHEN BY
THAT SAME YEAR TWENTY THIRTY
CALIFORNIA. HAS EVEN LONGER
HOTTER AND DRIER SONS. WITHOUT
ANY EXTREMELY ACTIONS THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE NOTHING CLOSE
TO THE CIVIC PLANNING FOR OLDER
. DIGNITARY ATTACH ON SURE THE
OLDER ADULTS THE QUESTION X. IN. FOR THE PRICE OF LONGER
HOTTEST GIVE THAT AIR
CONDITIONING AND ENERGY GETTING
. MAKE SURE YOU TO MATCH
INSTALLING OR SHADES ARE OTHER
SIMILAR IN. IN ARC THE OLDER
ADULTS CAN BE ACTED STILL TAKE
PUBLIC TRANSIT AB WITH THE B.
WORKING WITH THEIR DISTRICT ON
AIR POLLUTION MEASURES BETWEEN
YEAH ESPECIALLY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO VALLEY. I JUST CAN'T
DANGEROUS COMBINATION AIR
POLLUTION EXTREME. ACTUALLY
OLDER LOCAL PARK LONG POSITION
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH THE
STATE ON THE MAP OF THE WHITE.
AND GOVERNOR IS CRUCIAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IT
COULD HAVE A R. P. INVOLVING THE
PROCESS DO. IT WATER TO HAVE ANY
OTHER CALLERS- NO THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY VERY GOOD- WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IF THERE
ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEEING NONE WELL I
THINK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS AGAIN
FOR TESTIFYING TODAY IF YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY BE THE
TELECONFERENCE IS PLEASED TO
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS. OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS WILL
BE IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION THANK
YOU FOR PUTTING THE SPOTLIGHT.
ON THIS GROWING EMERGENCY AND
FOR EVERYONE AND FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION- HALF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT THIS
HEARING IS HEREBY ADJOURNED.